[Musique]
allô allô
tu as vu ce qui se passe à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok tech
[Musique]
non non
2 venu sur le plateau de tout le monde
en parle l'émission qui parle
avec nous ce soir nos euros
ce mec
moncorge également
léo sur les people
à
ça
les islamistes nous voient nous du
diable s'habille en prada
non le retour
ats djoko
mais bien engagée
vous aussi voir à roland garros à la tsr
sur france 2 et françois l'après midi
bon c'est vraiment le genre je prépare
déjà la retraite je vais au match de
tennis je n'apprends rien [__] rien
branler pas évident quand on est hyper
actif comme moi
je vais aller ça va aller très bientôt
une très bonne idée pour les tableaux
thierry que nous en parler oui l'idée
des tableaux c'est vrai alors voilà tous
les tableaux qui sont ici vous pouvez
les acheter au profit de l'oeuvre de
stéphanie fugain des plaquettes il
suffit d'aller sur un site tout le monde
en parle et puis voilà vous les achetez
ce sera un prix unique 1 c'est plus
simple non non non ce la baie saint
pascal et des toiles quand même qu'ils
seront plus chers que d'autres on vend
les photos de chaque toile bah oui c'est
luca ita gueule ça va perdre de la
valeur c'est sûr
et les gens vont monter les enchères sur
chaque toile assure tchèque chaque toile
laurent guerry qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avant de recevoir notre premier invité
d'habitude on regarde le best-of de la
semaine dernière et actuellement et s'y
préparer partie par un connard
navarro ah d'accord tu vas tu as changé
mais non c'est josé et c'est m6 et
magnéto serge
il ya un moment dans la vie où on a à la
fois je dirais la maîtrise on croit tout
cas avoir la maîtrise des choses et puis
on se fait virer comme des merdes
cependant les jeunes et quand je dis un
petit peu sous une autre
quel est celui ou celle
qui par son expérience
connaissant de l'appareil d'état et puis
je dirais son imagination c'est sa
vision pardon pour le maître service
jacquiau
là ça va être un enfer ces particules
jeu tu veux te laisser quelques l'oxo de
diction vous avez écrit hollande prudent
et du respect de l'éthique non
absolument il m'a répondu par une lettre
amical tu as raison et il a laissé moins
deux volets
résume
salon des gens dans son team
c'est moi qu'ils ne foulent pas je
résume alors la principale mesure de
jack lang pour le chômage pour vaincre
le chômage c'est de faire une grande
fête du chômage
ou les gens descendraient les on
descendait dans la rue n'était chômeurs
pour danser
malheureusement l'année que jamais
l'année leurs efforts commencé comme ça
ou gauche
north a été pratiquement la même sinon
si vous leur avez noël nous le savons
bien le
nom j'ai proposé à françois hollande que
nous facilitions les conditions
d'adhésion 20 euros sur internet essabah
et ça marche j'accueille
ça d'habitude c'est david une genève ri
comme ça on va en tout cas avant jeudi
voire 20 euros vous cliquez mieux vos
clics et que de recevoir une claque en
comme en 2002
l'a appelé il ya très longtemps vous
souvenez jack
nous sommes ne nous sommes appelés mais
nous ne sommes pas amis
on peut le devenir des zones à mes
cartes on aura tout essayé vous devez
supplier patrick de carolis de vous
reprendre
tu arrives à le faire
bon ils iront pensez quoi de la france
d'aujourd'hui là elle s'en remettra
l'année prochaine
si on veut me donner une île entourée de
requin ou où on mettra ou en mettent à
les condamner à vendre ensemble et il
trouvait et ils feront eux-mêmes leurs
polices et bavois la banque quand même
c'est le bagne que vous décrivez à
l'instant mais vous savez vous savez ce
qu était la monstruosité du bail vous
n'avez pas été assassinés donc vous ne
savez pas ce que c'est qu'un bon cru
aussi mais la tactique
c'est le charme de cette émission
j'aurais vu jouer star assis côte à côte
avec maurice mettait aussi aller bosser
pour me c'est pour moi
pouvait faire comme sa yo
vous devez chanter une chanson de bruel
en la massacre en on fait tenir avec
vous a dit ça mais je relève à la pomme
c'est un des grands hommes excuse est
radin au point de mettre de l'eau du
robinet dans des bouteilles d'eau
minérale non jamais non parce que je
connais une très bonne ou
est-ce que vous êtes radiant un point de
demander une prostituée de vous rendre
la monnaie
c'est pas un sport que je pratique vous
en trouvez pas non c'est trop cher
francis récemment dans paris match vous
avez avoué avoir découvert l'amour avec
un garçon ce qui est quand c'est d'aimer
quelqu'un c'est pas avec quel sexe on va
les mecquois ouais ouais non mais moi
moi si tu veux ce garçon je pense tous
les jours de ma vie tu as quelque chose
à lui dire la cites orga ben merci mais
t'as rien fait un bassiste
est-ce que vous jouez parfois de la
guitare à quatre heures du matin dans un
arbre ouais
ça va bien
alors aussi c'est incroyable ça te fait
rire mais est-ce que je vais nana maire
didier ça te fait sans déconner ça te
fait rire
mais ça allait donner pourquoi ça te
fait rire si c'est mon kiff parce que
t'es bon
6 est-ce que vous avez déjà eu envie de
mettre votre sexe dans un trou pour
faire l'amour avec la terre
écoute après avoir chanté dans l'arbre
paco rabanne la fille quand on rappelle
à
ceux qui font l'amour dans la terre
c'est parce qu'il ya une taupe c'est bon
on va y aller
c'est le destin
j'accueille laura smet et florence
moncorgé gabin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laurence qui passe alors à sa
recherche
s'est pas laissée pas les bonnes places
laurent je leur ai dit mes épaules
inversée si les autres et changer de
place on recense deux places bon on va
la refaire voilà
je me mets la gt fait piéger par laurent
qu'est ce que tu es formidable il ya un
ferme c'est marrant parce que ce soir je
reçois la fille de johnny hallyday et la
fille de jean gabin j'aurais pu faire
faire interview par ma fille
commence à mal aura alors voilà je vais
te dire le rang ça fait six mois qu'elle
me dit quand je viendrai dans ton
émission pour le field de florence je
t'en supplie ne me mets pas la chanson
lauréate en tunisie alors tu vois ça
fait pareil mais je ne vais pas me non
mais tu le dis ouais faut pas que je le
dise si si si si j'adore tulasne cette
chanson tu l aimes ton papa
maman papa autant écoute ça dépend des
jours non si j'aime beaucoup la chanson
mais bon c'est vrai que ça me paraît
très à l'aise tout de suite ouais non
puis c'est une chanson de tournus en
fait dans un concert tu avais six ans et
est ce qu on a tout le monde tu as
regardé et c'était un peu traumatisé
mais espère que oui il y avait d'un coup
tout bercy tu vas qui se retourne vers
toi tu as six ans et certains progrès ce
qui se passe tu vois que tu supportes
rémy aujourd'hui ouais si t'es à côté de
moi tout va bien sympa ce que veulent
ils je peux aller voter
on n en est pas là pour parler de vos
parents à toutes les deux on est là pour
parler du film de florence dans lequel
tu joues ça s'appelle le passager de
l'été avec catherine frot mathilde
seigner grégori derangère françois
berléand et toi droit ce soir le 7 juin
tu échoues est le pitch florence si tu
veux le faire ah oui non moi j'ai pas
envie de le faire donc ça prend bien
sinon je peux le faire moins bien
aléatoire face aux pays-bas ouais t'as
vu le film ouais pas mal alors voilà
heureusement je vais le faire
le pitch et c'est un peu théorème à le
film de pasolini
c'est une ferme dans les années 50 après
la guerre il n'y a pas d'homme parce que
beaucoup sont morts au combat
mais le mari de la patronne catherine
frot lui il est parti avec une gueuse
voilà il ya trois femmes dans cette
ferme il ya catherine frot donc dire et
grand mère est alors à qui la fille de
catherine frot voilà et à ce moment là
arrive à un ouvrier saisonnier joué par
grégori derangère et il va les aimer
toutes les deux c'est à dire catherine
frot et laura et la
cerda
exactement c'est une triangulaire qui
est qui et il ya eu maldonne ou des voir
puisque la mère admire l'ouvrier à cause
de son travail et que nuit admire la
jeune par le savoir que lui n'a pas
rencontré le pape à la grand mère c'est
toute la suisse
je sais pas ça il faudrait qu'une
génération c'est pas mal
alors le plus rance vous avez été levée
à la campagne vous ça se sent quand on
voit le film oui j'ai été assez
exigeante sur sur tout ce qui touche la
gestuelle et puis et puis les détails de
la campagne c'est quelque chose que j'ai
bien connu puis vous savez j'ai beaucoup
d'amis qui habite la campagne qui sont
agriculteurs ou qui travaillent dans
l'élevage donc ils m'ont dit attention
tu attends on t'attend au tournant donc
il fallait faire attention quand même
que votre père il était agriculteur en
fait c'est un paysan jabbar gaieté il
était paysan crie-t-il a commencé gabart
en 53 avec avec quelques lapins et un as
mais en 76 il avait 300 têtes de bétail
et 15 chevaux de course enfin les
chevaux de course c'était quand même une
danseuse alors que le bétail c'est
quelque chose qui bon an mal an
rapportent toujours s'en sont pris quoi
vous sauvez traire les vaches oui j'ai
appris quand au dessus mais curieusement
je n'ai pas appris avec chez mon père
parce qu'ils avaient la traite
électrique j'ai appris sur un film qui
s'appelle les granges brûlées que j'ai
tourné avec de longs et signoret et là
on m'a appris à travailler j'avais alors
justement là c'est un film qui se passe
au moment de l'arrivée de la
mécanisation à la la campagne c'est à
dire qu'à le premier tracteur tout ça
mais encore beaucoup de choses qui sont
assez archaïque dans le film à l'époque
où on était donc on est arrivé à la
campagne
il y avait encore des percherons qui
travaillaient ils sont restés quand même
très longtemps ses chevaux et j'ai vu
ces gens ont travaillé comme ça très
dure derrière les chevaux la charrette
tout ça et puis j'ai vu l'arrivée du
tracteur qu'on voit dans le film le
massey ferguson il y avait aussi des
renault mais c'était surtout les masses
et faire lui sommes en avait deux à la
maison et ça a révolutionné le monde
agricole complètement alors il ya une
espèce de sexualité sous jacente dans ce
film c'est que des regards que des gens
qui sait quand il traite des vaches
non c'est vrai catherine frot c'est la
première fois que je vois comme ça moi
elle est très très sexy dans ce film oui
mais c'était le c'était le but atteint
résidant à oui bravo à vous l'avez rendu
sexy désirable
c'était c'était le but à atteindre et
c'est effectivement ce qui laisse
qu'elle craignait le plus parce que
catherine est quelqu'un de très pudique
re très très pudique mais je ne pensais
pas à ce point là parce que c'est vrai
que on en avait quand même très peu
parlé avant le film on en avait un petit
peu parlé mais pas beaucoup et quand on
est arrivés justement les journées où il
a fallu tourner ses scènes j'ai bien
senti qu'il y avait quelques il y avait
il y avait des choses qu'il a qui la
gêne est quand même mais j'ai dit
catherine faut y arriver parce que c'est
moi c'est le point culminant quand même
de mon film ce n'est pas ça le film peut
tomber à plat donc c'était très
important il ya un moment elle est
allongée dans le lilla il ya le mec qui
arrive à luz son lit elle lui fait un
regard je n'aurais jamais pensé que
j'allais désir et catherine frot
avec désirable c'est ça et oui oui elle
a réussi quelque chose d'extraordinaire
alors évidemment il ya mathilde seigner
bon elle couche avec tout le monde mais
ça c'est la vie qui avait dit non non
dans le film mais ça c'est un scoop
c'est assez voilà c'est plus attendu que
catherine frot voilà ce que je veux dire
oui oui lauriane aura alors ma chère
laura le look 50 voix très très bien
vous êtes magnifique dans ce film très
héroïne de roman et alors vous jouez le
rôle d'une institutrice alors ça c'est
vraiment un rôle de composition parce
que laura changer d'école à peu près
tous les bijoux et qu'elle ne sait ni
lire ni
pourquoi vous changer d'école parce que
vous en aviez marre que tous les élèves
vous dise ah que coucou parce que
non non non parce que je n'arrivais pas
à rentrer dans le moule scolaire c'est
vraiment un truc moi quand je suis
obligé de faire quelque chose je ne le
fais pas voilà et donc laura n'y est pas
arrivé leur art et essai
en coin voilà c'est ça
non mais c'est pas mal mais en tout cas
c'était en tout cas pour moi de faire ce
film là j'espère que mes profs
venir dans leur estime oui et voilà donc
non c'était amusant pour moi espèce de
revanche enfin je me suis si j'arrive à
faire ça j'arriverai peut-être à faire
des trucs qui m'impressionne pas encore
plus non vous êtes très bien dans le
film alors c'est vrai que le cinéma cc
c'est différent c'est la première fois
vous dites que j'arrive à terminer
quelque chose avant c'était une horreur
j'arrivais à rien finir même pas un
livre avant et c'est vrai que quand je
pense est un livre je finissais peine
pas aidé dans les dernières pages je
sais pas j'avais un truc que j'aime bien
ne pas finir les choses et là tu es
obligé parce que tu vas santé sous
contrat
et un tri chambre et à florence pourquoi
me fais le premier film à votre âge fin
à notre aise
à notre âge mais
vous savez je disais à votre âge
voudrait dire qu'on a pas le même guéri
alors pourquoi on fait un film à notre
âge ben est parce qu en fait quel âge
exactement continent les basques qui
relança se fait pas demander l'âge de
ensuite parce qu'ils se mêlent que celui
de thierry moi j'ai
le même
âge que moi je moi je trouve thierry en
pleine forme donc oui il a beaucoup
baissé
une des mauvaises nouvelles récemment et
là
voilà pourquoi pourquoi citer à cet âge
non pourquoi si tard florent soit si
tard alors pourquoi si tard justement
parce que en fait que moi j'ai réalisé
mon premier court métrage donc en 86
j'avais dans l'idée de continuer après
ce court métrage justement a écrit en
russe ou ou de refaire un court métrage
ou de faire un long métrage et puis
s'est trouvé que ma vie un petit peu
changé et que j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
avec qui je suis parti habiter la
campagne il a encore presque
pratiquement un vélo un plouc voilà
comme les parisiennes disent exactement
habitants des moyens voilà donc nous
sommes année élevé des rendez vous au
lieu des machins pas d'accord ouais et
moi pendant quinze ans je me suis retiré
complètement du monde du cinéma donc
j'ai absolument pas pensé par contre
j'ai écrit pendant ce temps là je n'ai
pas perdu mon temps mais je n'ai pas
fait de j'ai pas réalisé c'est en
rentrant à paris après que heureusement
que c'est terminé c'est à nouveau ce
film exactement ça très bien qu'on soit
séparé au cinémarine markit est comme ça
au moins j'ai quelque chose intéressante
lorsque vous allez faire maintenant
toutes les deux je vais regarder votre
caméra celle où yann rouge fermé
lederman et e serge ensemble attention
sinon ça marche pas attention dans la
caméra florence c'est le cas le rouge
attention rôle aura un deux trois
magnéto serge magique
qu'est ce que vous voulez je cherche du
travail américain aurait peut-être ce
qui vous a dit ça un gars sur le chemin
et sa jument
j'espère vous n'êtes pas fignon ça veut
dire que c'est oui
joseph il mettrait de côté deux sauts
pour le beurre et fromage blanc vous
savez les faire et fromage blanc
bonjour maman bonjour ma fille siècle a
molli qu'elle a un nouveau comité est
alors question que ça à foot c'est un
beau gâchis c'est même un sacré bestiaux
donc aimé navire est dans quoi
ils pouvaient pas l'emmener lui-même
sont là j'ai rêvé devant le souvenir ton
et fait autant pour fernand dit ici tout
ça mais je suis sûr que tout le monde
pense qu'on va coucher ensemble jamais
prenez soin et danse bien la commune ta
mère est pas mal mais dont il se prend
pas pour une merde il ya les noms
singulier et les non plus réalisé moi ça
par exemple pourquoi est ce qu'il est
parti qui ça rit ça vous regarde pas
vous êtes mon employé joseph
m
[Musique]
joseph
des choses qui me plaisent pas tu
apprends à lire et à écrire c'est un
crime va lui servir à quoi on désherber
combien je l'aimais mains jetables
voilà le passager de l'été de florence
moncorgé gabin
de race nette entre autres invités ce
soir voilà
ces prix d'orry dérangère ils sont un
peu à gabin dans l'est dans les films
des années 30 ou 40 ha oui je trouve
j'étais simple nature comme ça
authentique authentique
c'est peut-être pas un hasard
certainement pas un hasard il est
porteur de valeurs qui avaient à
l'époque pourquoi oublier non plus quand
50 y avait certaines valeurs qui
n'existe plus maintenant et peut-être
que ces valeurs là rappelle le gamin
d'entre les deux guerres c'est ça ouais
c'est un type qui bossent un album on
bossait à l'époque y avait pas les 35
heures
vous trouvé séduisant vos grégori
derangère par son talent en tout cas
tu mouilles pas beaucoup la non sans
rire que je trouve très beau mc
je regarde pas trop les hommes
sur leurs chansons attention maintenant
je veux dire que non mais oui mais en
tout cas c'est vrai que de travailler
avec lui c'est quelqu'un de très
généreux et voilà c'est un peu la
première fois je trouve j'ai vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler
c'est clair non mais vraiment je dire tu
le trouvent séduisant ou pas oui
beaucoup de plaisir là
pas un rapport avec ben et les par
exemple a rien à voir c'est le travail
c'est vrai avoir dit non j'ai lu gala
moi
non mais tu l'as dit voilà enfin de
rendre ses élus ses sorties ouais tu as
dit que le premier vrai je t'aime de ta
vie c'était frédéric c'est vrai c'est
vrai il ya de la chanson frédéric
guesdon
tu as dis je pourrais faire n'importe
quoi par amour
non mais c'est formidable qu'est-ce que
je peux faire n'importe quoi en tout
aussi par amour il est jaloux des
acteurs federec non en toile et il le
montre pas ah ouais quand tu étais avec
grégori derangère là il n'était pas non
il ne montre pas du tout j'aimerais bien
qu'il soit plus jaloux d'ailleurs si
l'on regarde soit un tout petit peu plus
jaloux ce garçon
mais en même temps tu dis quand on me
demande de faire l'amour à l'écran il
faut pas faire la fine bouche
bats pas tu nous mourrons lis un
scénario et qu'on dit oui pour un rôle
et qu'on la lui et que c'est pas gratuit
et que pour les corps impatients il y
avait une scène à 3 g pas vincee c'est
pas
si ça a à voir avec l'histoire il n'ya
pas fauqué une histoire quoi oui un
porno avec un bon scénario
de toute façon il a déclaré que dans la
fiction on peut réaliser toutes nos
envies formidable dans la zone bien bas
on ne fait pas on va pas passer la
soirée avec une en métal puis encore 12
presque
sinon on va pas passer soirée johnny et
frédéric et tout ça non on va faire un
hardi view
alors vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
j'ai un peu peur de tes questions
quand vous regarder dans la glace le
matin vous dites quoi
je parle rarement à moi même le matin
tueur et aimer ressembler à qui quand tu
étais petit
vanessa paradis ah ouais je les adore
depuis tout le temps toujours ouais t'as
plus belle histoire d'amour
en ce moment ah ouais mais moins pour
vivre heureux vivons cachés on va dire
ça comme ça ouais
est-ce que tu serais prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour ta carrière
tu es parents la france
ta religion
oui ah oui
oui mais je pense que si même il ne
demandera pas
quand on demande une autographes tu
signes ou quoi ls
je suis pas comme ça les gens peuvent
s'imaginer que trop g de lusine cynisme
quand est-ce que tu as pleuré pour la
dernière fois alors c'était à cannes
pour la projection de marie-antoinette
tout à fait pleurer et huawei mais
pourtant il la tue pas dans le film ah
oui mais aussi pour ça que ça m'a fait
pleurer tu vas et messieurs j'ai adoré
ah ouais c'est la première personne que
je vois qu'il j'avais lu
l'autobiographie g soit j'adore sa vie
cette femme est comme ça et c'est vrai
que le film trouve que c'est déjà d'une
beauté incroyable et oui j'ai été très
ému je sais pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que tu changerais en toi si tu
avais une baguette magique
j'essaierai de transformer mon angoisse
en sérénité
mais peut-être que je m'ennuierais plus
sais pas quel péché qui vous tente le
plus
la paresse
et oui et je le sais je le sais parce
que frédéric maladie
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire des plus
négatives sur vaud en ce moment j'ai
accepté des sacs gratuits pas mal c'est
un petit peu honteux donc j'essaie de
les donner
oui c'est assez négative c'est bien six
lettres vie était à refaire qu'est-ce
que vous changeriez
sans doute de l'adolescence parce que ça
arriver tôt ça a duré trop longtemps et
c'est un âge que je trouve très ingrat
je recommencerai pas ça ouais quelle
insulte qui t'a fait le plus mal à part
madame beigbeder qui fait
je crois que c'était à l'école c'était
un prof qui m'avait dit que
qu'avec mon nom j'avais pas besoin de
faire des études et c'est pour ça que ça
m'a appelé c'est parce que sa vérité
blesse qui as-tu le plus envie d'épater
dans la vie
mes parents
on n'est qu'à la mer oui comme téléphone
sonne t heureuse ou agacer
ses dépens quel nom s'affiche quelle est
la dernière chose que tu fais le soir
avant de se coucher laura
l'amour
ça les filles d'aujourd'hui je me rends
pas compte fait pas de film
qu'est-ce que tu ferais site rester 24
heures à vivre
l'appareil pareil pendant 24 heures
d'accord pas quel est le surnom qu'on te
donne que tu es croire non je suis
obligé de dire ça
c'est new new new new york c'est
horrible l'union
c'est pour ça comme ça tu pour éviter de
m'appeler comme ça elle s'ennuie cette
annonce je dirais pas qu'ils n'ont tout
à refaire un deal j'étais le dire on
t'appelle pas dit non non non
c'est compris mieux
qu est la dernière personne que tu envie
de tuer moi
quand tu dis toi tu parles de niaux
et dieu dans tout ça
j'y crois pas ah bon mais
je pense à céret qu'il ya pas longtemps
j'ai dans mon bain j'essaie de réciter
notre père c'est bien comme endroit
c'était bénitier géant c'est bien ça
c'était non mais ça part d'un bon
sentiment aussi bien tu vois ce que tu
as fait du bien ouais continue qu'est ce
que la vie vous a appris être heureux
c'est maintenant ou jamais j'ai peint le
présent le bonheur c'est maintenant ou
jamais
comment aimerais tu mourir c'est pas
comme jim morrison dans un bain
quel est le mot que tu ne supporte pas
d'entendre pargneaux bien fait
je crains le pire avec ce nul en ce
moment c'est clearstream
ah ouais parce que je trouve ça laid en
temps mort à israël cheval français oui
je comprends pas très bien ce qui s'est
passé en fait rien j non plus
c'est pas tout seul est-ce que tu as
menti pendant cette interview je suis
comédienne
laurie bérengère catherine
soit à faire les
[Musique]
m
ah
c'est quoi ces cartes à johnny
d'ailleurs
vous devez chanter leur à optic 2000
je suis flatteur sur laquelle des deux
états
c'est très peu invasives jeu après jeu
mais 13 heures à la petite demie
m
et
il voit atol les opticiens
c'est moins classe mk-5 optique 2000
j'accueille nolwenn leroy
wayne allwine va arriver en attendant on
va écouter la cartomancienne
[Applaudissements]
ma chemise de nuit parce que je savais
que j'allais passer la nuit ici est
bonne je me suis habillé directement
fait très bien à l'om j'ai déclaré en
février dernier dans télé star pour le
moment je me sens pas prête à aller chez
ardisson voilà qu'est ce qui vous a fait
changer d'avis le mois de mars après
après vous avoir rencontré
voilà ce que vous êtes venu dîner à la
maison exactement et avoir passé
quelques moments avec laurent baffie
attention on a tous une vie privée
d'affaires regarde landes non jamais non
on a chanté on a chanté ah oui justement
pour pour l'association laurette fugain
alors je répète donc que tous les
tableaux qui sont là seront bientôt sur
un site internet vendu au profit de
l'association laurette fugain ceux qui
n'ont pas d'argent ont quand même des
plaquettes on veut donner également
leurs plaquettes arrive à la prescrire
dans les centres alors au sujet de la
star faisait déclaré plein de points
négatifs mais c'est le positif qui l'a
emporté au final si je devais
recommencer je recommencerai
oui parce que parce que c'est une
expérience qui m'a permis de me faire
entendre et
voilà habitant en province tu as vu que
nous perdons
vichy voilà un nom jésus christ de
mondeville et salue les chiffres
auxquels ils font ça elvire au sujet
d'un trop tard tu es viré trop tard
comme je suis en panique en auvergne
voilà donc on cède on salue la bretagne
sa mère
non mais sérieusement puisque vous avez
habité à saint-yorre à vichy evian c'est
de la merde
maintenant j'habite toujours à sainthia
j'habite maison de famille alors donc
oui il y avait cent mille cassette qui
ont été envoyés un cent mille cas sept
mois je me suis filmé dans la douche
ouais c'est appelé mir acoustique c'est
ça tu as raison bon allez donc mais très
lucide quand même après la star avait
déclaré c'est maintenant que je vais
avoir à galérer c'est maintenant que ça
va être décisif et le 4 mars 2003 après
un mois de deux studios faisait sentir
votre premier album gains
voilà donc ça c'était le premier album
avec kc je n'ai vendu 500 milles mais
j'avais dit c'est le deuxième album qui
sera décisif hélas s'ensuit un long
silence discographique mais aussi
médiatique vous avez décidé de
disparaître un silence radio pendant
plusieurs mois c'est pas vraiment un
silence radio c'est qu'on m'a énormément
vu pendant une très courte période à
cause du manque bien sûr de l'émission à
laquelle j'ai participé ont été
extrêmement médiatisé puis d'un coup je
me suis juste en fermant studio j'ai
travaillé sur mes textes et toute cette
période de création là forcément c'est
difficilement associable avec avec une
exposition médiatique et bien j'ai fait
silence pourquoi on entendrait que le
vote
il ya des gens qui étaient venus sharek
mal à
quitter west neiges pas ces sales
histoires raisons qui
restent
en même temps qu'ils baissent un peu la
guerre les gens vont moins que la coupe
et la clim
dit un petit peu d'air jeu mais non ça
va mais moi je suis habillé cjd manche
oui c'est vrai non non mais on est un
peu c'est vrai on savait pas si con lamy
un blouson en cuir se
sert de son secours ouais bah récents
tournois en noir ça c'est très sortie ça
me fait plaisir bah oui donc sinon c'est
en fait pour travailler puis mieux faire
entendre votre voix quand vous quand
vous reviendrez c'est ce qui s'est passé
vous avez travaillé sur un deuxième
album donc avec laurent voulzy alors il
démarre avec laurent voulzy c'est long
ça le problème de laurent boullier s'est
pas tellement pour écrire des mélodies
derrière un silence et j'ai appris c'est
même pas un problème c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les albums s'enchaînent très
rapidement et forcément aussi lorsqu'on
est seulement interprète on va chercher
des chansons comme c'est un peu partout
et sa tendance à aller plus vite mais
lorsqu'on écrit lorsqu'on concret ça ça
prend plus de temps c'est artisanal est
vrai que laurent
il écrit et compose extrêmement vite
mais lui c'est plus la réalisation du
temps j'apprends du temps un ouais alors
cette absence des médias a quand même
été assez mal interprété par par
certains par vos détracteurs qui va
encore me revient toujours
ouais on m'a dit que vous étiez fini à 1
on m'a dit que cette union à qui on dit
qu'elle n'est pas finie mois
non mais c'est vrai que le véritable
métier d'un chanteur d'un artiste c'est
de composer créé en studio puis ensuite
de présenter ses chansons sur scène bien
sûr il ya la télé compte aussi mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas ce qui compte
le plus tu entends francis
lalanne
faire des chansons
donc pendant ce temps là vous avez bâti
les les fondations qui manquait à votre
carrière donc vous avez pris le temps de
faire un album qui vous ressemble un
album s'appelle histoire naturelle au
pluriel et deux enfants ils sont grands
c'est sorti en décembre dernier et il ya
un premier single qui a fait un carton
déjà
je suis
ça c'est une chanson j'ai cosigné avec
jean rampon les souches ans
et maintenant et maintenant vient le
deuxième single de l'album histoire
naturelle qui s'appelle aussi l'histoire
naturelle
ouaga
[Musique]
c
je
voilà l'histoire naturelle extrait de
l'histoire mathieu le besoin
ben non
alors maintenant
on n'a pas vu ça depuis maurice druon
des les applaudit francis lalanne
vous avez regardé votre caméra c'est le
cadre rouge vous avez dire magnéto serge
attention ah non non c'est bon t'es prêt
magnéto serge salut
m
je ne veux lui
je ne change
[Musique]
soit
l'histoire nationale
c'est chez mercuria monsieur
nolwenn leroy en tournée dans toute la
france et le 9 et 10 octobre à l'olympia
cette salle de l'olympia ou lors de
votre première performance vous avez
rencontré laurent voulzy laurent avec
qui j'avais chanté un duo paravent qui
est venu me voir ce soir là et qui m'a
proposé de jouer ensemble on travaille
vous êtes devenu s'amuse
je pense qu'effectivement
laurent a écrit pour très peu de
personnes dans sa carrière et je crois
qu'il a besoin d'être inspiré d'une
manière ou d'une autre pour pour écrire
des chansons pour quelqu'un nous donc
c'est une relation enfin sincèrement ces
mois-là d'amour platonique d'un mètre
dans une élévation m m m des normes et
jeu
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
jaser sur cette histoire et c'est en
fait pas du tout c'est un amour
complètement platonique je vais profiter
de la télévision pour le dire oui dans
les gens profitent pour le dire parce
que c'est vrai que c'est pour la femme
de laurence oui en plus l'exemple
aucun souci non mais c'est en tout cas
je suis privilégié d'avoir pu apprendre
à ses côtés pendant tous ces mois passés
en studio de gestion que tu te
connaissais
ses parcs auzits à
19,1 m non mais c'est vrai que comme
vous avait personne dans votre vie on a
toujours tendance à vous attribuer des
as ça s'est arrangé à l'achat
oui c'est la mieux alors non parce qu'à
un moment on a même dit que vous étiez
lesbienne
mais vous le savez en fait la surprise
mais elle m'a dit à moi on a dit il ya
très longtemps parce que ma meilleure
amie à l'époque coucher avec moi
hall au château et
stack été était lesbienne donc tout le
monde en a conclu et d'ailleurs je sais
assez bas de honte honte incroyable
voyage bien comme on peut être ses amis
émiratis aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui est vrai alors nolwenn
qu'est ce qui est vrai et ce qui est pas
vrai c'est plus simple ce qui est pas
vrai c'est voulzy et lesbiennes les
lesbiennes
nolwenn n'avait jamais été très branché
part ça vous ait déclaré que quand vous
étiez plus jeune vous préfériez passer
vos week-ends à jouer de la musique
plutôt que de vous ennuyer avec un mec
quand j'étais plus jeune mais plus
jeunes n'ont effectivement mais oui
parce que j'étais au collège au lycée à
la fac toute la semaine effectivement le
peu de temps loisirs dont je disposais
je veux consacrer à la musique donc mais
bon je me suis pas sûr
non mais je me suis rattrapé après et
aujourd'hui tout va bien tout va bien
vous fumez pas vous buvez pas je mets
pas les bois non pas que j'aime pas
c'est que j'ai pas vraiment l'occasion
mais ouais non je
nom qui vous plaît c'est le cheval en
fait c'est comme ça qu'on s'est connus
ben dis donc tu te vantes
voltige me vient je dois le poney et
encore
avec le mieux en astarac vous avez
acheté un marocain noir s'appelle à
berkane qui est un très bon cheval et
les papiers ou pas
barbe marocain et que tu meurs je suis
votre cousine en normandie de chez moi
en fait on est voisins avec nolwenn
ouais on se croise dans le train d'un
immatériel voilà
[Musique]
un malware j'étais une star
académicienne est devenu une star en
véritable star
est-ce que depuis que vous êtes star
c'est plus facile avec les garçons non
parce que justement j'ai c'est d'être
avec des gens qui savent pas vraiment
faim pas qu'ils savent pas ce que je
fais mais qui connaissent pas vraiment
mon métier afin qu'ils sont peut-être
pas dit si tu n'aimes pas ta musique
voilà qui n'aime pas jouer la fin est-ce
que depuis que vous êtes star vous payez
encore vos vêtements ah oui ah oui je
devais vous êtes ça au fait des doigts
d'honneur aux paparazzi
non parce que j'ai jamais l'occasion de
les voir malheureusement si j'ai voyez
je pourrais le faire mais c'est toujours
par surprise voilà toi tu fais des
tu les vois pas est-ce que depuis que
ses soeurs faisait virer tous vos
anciens amis
non au contraire j'ai très peu de
nouveaux amis en fait j'ai presque que
des anciens amis que ce soit mes amis de
deux collèges de lycées et tous mes amis
des etats-unis ce que j'ai vécu un an un
an aux états unis donc j'ai tous les
amis étudiants en échange et puis mes
amis américains non non vous avez amusé
à la noue mois et voilà une meilleure
des chances
est-ce que depuis que j'ai dix darbouka
c'est tout dans les chambres d'hôtel en
fait le genre de chambres d'hôtels dans
lesquels je descends pendant les
tournées y'a pas grand chose a cassé
dans les chambres bloquées jusqu'à trois
grands jeux et toi tu casse tout la
chambre haute m
vous réagissez comme ans quand on vous
fait prendre l'avion en deuxième place
je réagis bien parce que je les prie 1
il ya une semaine en 2e classe l'avion
et je vais super bien ça va ouais ouais
ouais les petites jambes maintenant oui
j'ai des petites gens mais puis oui mais
pas vraiment la différence entre la la
business c'est la classe fait gaffe de
faire sauter la défense de vedettes
comme un petit enfant mort né est-ce que
depuis que cette soirée des prix sur la
drogue ouais non je n'ai jamais fumé non
mais c'est vrai qu'on a je vous jure
c'est bon c'est un pas besoin de boire
ou fumer je m'amuse très bien tout seul
est ce que le vix est d'ores et déjà
exigé une table dans un restaurant
complet exigé non dit mon nom en
appelant une fois il y a
il ya justement juste après le concert
pour le fus bien j'étais dîner avec
maurane et j'ai appelé un restaurant et
j'ai dit qu'on était tout les deux voire
une table c'était trop mal de
s'organiser
quand un fan vous reconnaît dans la rue
vous montez les vitres de la voiture en
vitesse thierry il ya des boutons
maintenant pour
arranger la station
rattrapé par mon âge j'ai c'est l'époque
des tracteurs massey ferguson lance
les sacs de jute à 4
4 chevaux dans ton film est excellent
est ce que maintenant vous êtes sans
penser que les critiques sont tous des
cons et surtout ceux de libé
je ne sais pas si mon album j'ai des
chroniques et dans libé me semble pas
mais récemment j'ai trouvé j'ai eu un
truc très sympa sur moi non rock'n folk
et ça c'est quand même énorme et c'est
bien c'est très content
non mais sincèrement danger est ce que
maintenant vous êtes star vous refusez
d'années dans des soirées où il n'ya pas
de cadeaux offerts
je vais pas dans les soirées et pas
surtout celles où il ya des cadeaux
offerts laura tu y vas toi n'ont jamais
pu y aller n'ont jamais pu rencontrer
beigbeder dans une forêt quartier leurs
données recueillies dans les quartiers
c'est peut-être sympa
est-ce que vous avez déjà zappé michel
drucker qui essayez de vous joindre ah
non jamais d'ailleurs j'ai participé
récemment à plusieurs émissions et
michel drucker et gt1 j'étais ravi c'est
vrai qu'ils baissent
si énormément
est ce que maintenant que cette star
vous attaquer systématiquement quand on
parle de vous dans voici oui moi
systématiquement est ce que maman vous
êtes star vous imposer qu'on parle pas
de certaines choses dans les interviews
non je ne faisais rien j'appose rien jeu
j'en parle pas tu voudrais qu'on parle
pas de quoi ce soir particulière non
pas vous non justement vous en avez pas
parlé encore
non vous n'avez pas demandé de nom je
trouve que c'est mieux de pas en parler
non mais ce soir sort des donc
c'est très sympa peux pas en parler bien
que ça me dérange pas forcément d'en
parler mais il ya des histoires qui
valent pas la peine qu'on en parle en
fait je crois qu'il faut le dire quand
même parce que la wii est bien sinon les
téléspectateurs vont pas comprendre les
mots tout mon enfance mon père on a
beaucoup parlé lorsque je suis sorti
effectivement été révélée par c'est vrai
que bon la lui c'est un peu partout et
je crois que j'ai pas envie de tout cas
ne pas lui faire cet honneur mais c'est
une histoire qui n'est pas forcément
extrêmement intéressante et fallait que
mon endroit donc voilà donc on en a
parlé
[__]
bien
[Musique]
à 1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
cartomancienne tu l'avais vivant deviner
la carte vous devinez
quoi vous devez nous raconter votre
dernière nuit d'amour au
dans le box
c'était alors je vais juste dire c'était
y'a pas longtemps mais c'était pas en
france
c'était plutôt en
amérique du nord oui vers new york par
la non côte ouest 1 c'est là où tu étais
partirait pour les échanges
pour les échanges c'est encore lui qui a
revu dingo
alain mimoun
[Musique]
quel succès c'est dingue je ne savais
pas que bing ligne ou qui étaient là
ce soir les lions qui est des
voix la carrière de miu miu ça va ça n'a
pas empêché de faire une carrière ce
dimanche j'ai choisi un tout plu au cap
a fait carrière
carrière ça va et il ya elle ça va bien
hélas oui elle va bien elle va très bien
on va lui demander on l'appelle yeah
yeah
un invité mystère il a posé des
questions et on répond par oui ou par
non de le deviner qui sait s qui brident
je me cachais
bayal apparemment
bon ce qu'on va faire si on va égaliser
un peu et on va désépaissir on va
retirer des volumes france on vous
raconte lire également
d'accord 8 du boulot ce soir les bulls
et j'avais une question on est sur
quelle chaîne c'est toujours le même là
on est sur l'a2 encore toujours la 2e
journée de
super bien
on s'en sort bien
fait pour l'heure s'il s'était converti
au judaïsme pour vous mais il a changé
le bouddhisme ou
alors tu restes de boutoir nantes et
asilah telles observations avant tout
c'est le sens thann acuité visuelle un
incroyable
lavit levitt et ça c'est quoi
si j'étais très
bons amis vous êtes ici pour un film
vous êtes ici bravo d'élite avec ma
femme avec votre femme est ce normal
tellement mignonne c'est vrai tous
témoignent oui vous êtes ici pour un
film dont vous êtes scénariste
réalisateur co producteur acteur si ça
se présente ne va pas demander et puis à
qui la faute sur les conseils de laurent
baffie j'ai fait pour la proposition des
conseils avisés
alors ce film s'appelle la maison du
bonheur c'est l'adaptation de votre
pièce la vie de chantier le titre a été
choisi par yaël qui ne connaissait pas
son sens de francis lalanne sinon vous
auriez pas prescrire non
non non elle c'est non j ai un comme la
chanson we france il me fait ce constat
ne supporte ward équipe de france a
les nerfs ya elle était inscrite au
générique du film est tout bleu et a
fait honneur
à la travailler sur le fond elle a
travaillé sur le film vous avez déclaré
là était mon miroir sur toutes les
phases de l'écriture elle a visionné les
rush elle a suivi de montage tout ça en
s'occupant du mouflet en plus non ils
agissent et c'est
oui et il n' est d'ailleurs le même jour
que yaël né le même jour à deux sortes
chasser les juifs c'est pour un gâteau
c'est l'économie c'est nice est marrant
dany sérieusement à quel point les
femmes de votre vie ont toujours été
mêlé à votre travail comment ça se fait
mais j'ai beaucoup travaillé tiré jeudi
et ouais on est très bon on n'a pas vécu
tellement longtemps ensemble non on
s'est pas marié déjà mla n'a pas réussi
à avoir d'enfants et voilà nommé judith
godrèche déjà été très impliquée dans
votre vie professionnelle oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai je m'attaque de vous et s'est
assise à côté de moi pour voir qu'en
juillet si je rie et c'est vrai dans le
très pro 1 ouais non mais pourquoi vous
êtes si impliqué avec vos aux femmes
dans le travail je sais pas impliqué
avec mes femmes c'est plus ces pagnes
s'est pas d'abord sur un univers de
femmes c'est une histoire de rencontre
donc il se trouve que effectivement il
ya elle que j'ai donc enlevé de suisse
puisqu'elle et les suissesses
voilà la halle a quitté son travail
il se trouve qu'elle a qu'elle a des
dons pas mal de dons et voilà et puis on
travaille ensemble effectivement elle a
fait donc sur la pièce elle a la cote
chez gym soualem pour l'accent portugais
elle a fait les chorégraphies ce café de
la danse à la fait toutes les grandes
chorégraphies de mon spectacle à chanter
sur des chansons dont spectacle à la
maison du bonheur donc de dany boon avec
michèle laroque daniel prévost zinedine
soualem laurent gamelon line renaud et
et vous bien sûr sortie de 7 juin alors
le pitch c'est un mari radin qui décide
d'être enfin généreuse va bien les
cheveux bas
alors le pitch donc c'est l'histoire
d'un mari radin qui décide d'être enfin
généreux avec sa femme en lui offrant
une maison de campagne mais pour faire
des économies il fait confiance à un
agent immobilier douteux qui lui
proposent des ouvriers foire voilà et là
surprise se transforme en cauchemar et
se termine en pur des liens vraiment
c'est une catastrophe c'est très drôle
bah merci ouais bon voir à quoi ça
ressemble j'ai regardé votre caméra
c'est le cal rouge ou yaël vous regardez
celle qu'elle a on va te faire pour la
première fois un lancement raser si la
voix n'a pas qu'on fait ça ces
lancements strabisme
ali vakili magnéto l'autre qui dit serge
voilà vous dites magnéto et vous vous
dites serge attendait inverse non non
vous changez de chiffre d'affaires dans
cette émission cette édition est déjà
assez compliqué comme ça a rien à faire
laurent magnéto vous et vous vous dites
c'est attention il va s'arrêter juste
quand les gens vont commencer à un
harnais messieurs
2,3 à temps comme vous le faites si vous
êtes prêts bien sûr on est d'accord là
dessus sur normal que tu sois prêt
attention vous êtes prêts attention il
ya des prairiales tu dises faire de toi
attention un deux trois
taux
serge
portelli avec les relevés de banque dab
à non dans 20 minutes c'est demi tarif
c'est pas grave c'est ma femme parce que
je suis à la bourre un appel mais
c'était pas comme ça avant tu es devenu
radin
brad a moins radins oui mais bonjour
excusez moi je veux juste un
renseignement concernant une maison en
vitrine elle est vendue non je plaisante
je te rappelle sadi keller 11h10 sais
pas
oui
alors on a à peine bougé de paris enfin
roland bien bien regardez moi cette
véranda comme celle humide j'en ai mal
aux yeux
[Musique]
par quel bout 15 15 mais faut quand même
faire une visite surtout pas malheur
elle fait la fête lui la surprise patron
qui va devoir qui vous a autorisé à
visiter des maisons pendant vos heures
de bureau je pensais pas qu'il y
arrivera 4 gérer il faut pas moins de
neuf chez tecmo faire des trains surtout
pas ou alors mon lot de mamie et pirani
mais bien comme ça qu'est ce que vous
voulez comme travaux
vous n'avez pas un déclin c'est que
quand on est perdu qu'on a besoin de
plans
nous a dit qu'il fallait qu'on profite
de la vie alors j'ai acheté une voiture
la c30 eurobonds allociné interdit
bancaire mais interdit bancaire plus de
carte bleue piqué qui est tombée des
travaux coûtent beaucoup plus cher que
prévu expliquez-moi pourquoi japon là
partout qu'est ce qui pend là partout
mais là les câbles à portola a justement
à propos des cas vous voulez vous
demandez vous les voulez cacher dans un
faux plafond ou comme ça toute apparence
et prenez votre meilleur et québec mais
c'est ma meilleure div on essayait de
cacher je vais vous mettre en arrêt
maladie
[Musique]
jamais déménagé aujourd'hui la déménager
ça ça va aller en ménage est plus
difficile
j'ai trouvé les gaz
[Applaudissements]
dany sortie le 16
oui et je suis venu avec lui aussi
intervenu à la commune
[Musique]
messieurs comment ça va bien il est prêt
pour la promo l'a pas mal bâle a pas
marre de répéter un peu là on va répéter
un peu la promo au départ dany boon
cette histoire de travaux est inspiré
d'une histoire vécue oui l'histoire des
moulures par exemple et la baguette
entre autres c'était un appartement
genre haussmannien la jolie avec des
belles moulures et l'architecte voit une
baguette de téléphone en plastique et
voilà il dit il il prend un de ces gars
il dit tu me vois tu m'enlèves la non
1,10 par lasser ses durement et le gars
dit oui
j'aurais dû me méfier le fait bien et
puis voilà et donc on part voir le truc
parler les plans les machins trucs et on
revient un quart d'heure après il avait
enlevé toutes les moulures sauf la terre
s'il croyait que la baguette était plus
moderne en pastique donc il disait ça
faut que ça reste élevée bien allait
bien il avait fait un petit pas il avait
fait un petit avec l' on aurait dit
qu'il allait faire un petit feu de camp
et j'ai dit les moulures les volumes
comme ça il m'a dit ah ça va vous
frappez pas je vais les remettre et il
les a remis un peu de travers il ya
aussi la peinture dans le sanitaire la
peinture dans le sanitaire c'est quand
il a émis la peinture dans le sanitaire
ça a débouché le sanitaire oui ça serait
sans ça oui c'est le félon vas voir
c'est ça sert essence et il ya trois
semaines à la campagne
le nom il avait vidé
oui de la peinture qui a séché dans un
coup de l'évacuation de toilette et donc
quelqu'un à nos invités à tirer la
chasse d'eau et au lieu de la facture
rire
ça fait le dos l'autre côté et on était
dans l'embarras et ça a fait le long des
murs comme ça et donc non ils ont été
réussis ont dû tout casser et ont pour
refaire les coudes tous les coudes si
vous êtes angoissé dany boon oui bon ça
c'est la question une question qu'on va
te poser beaucoup dans la promotion vous
êtes un angoissé dany boon est ce que
vous étiez angoisses et derrière la
caméra non j'étais pas gt non j'étais ça
allait non j'étais pas trop angoissé non
j'ai beau j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
film en préparation justement pour pour
pas l'être dany boon vous préférez
devant ou derrière
peut-être un peu posé la question il
faut que tu me rien de spécialement de
référence est beaucoup plus confortable
d'être devant oui que derrière
lui demandait sur
votre passé de storyboarder est
photographe vous a aidé c'est tout à
fait vrai thiery je vois que vous êtes
bien renseigné je ne comprends pas
pourquoi vous faites licence qui de le
france 2
bardin votre émission et je trouve ça
complètement quand
oui j'étais dessinateur
gt2 et storyboarder donc effectivement
j'ai appris à découper une histoire en
plan que ce soit en france en outre il a
beaucoup bossé sur ce film il a beaucoup
bossé sur ce fils qui a boosté le groupe
c de 5 heures du matin à minuit tu te
rien oui c'est vrai j'ai bossé
énormément
là on prépare la promo là
il y avait un truc super drôle sur le
tournage je peux raconter une anecdote
eu ce que tu veux en escrime pour une
des sept dernières éditions au tir et
patrick si tu m'entends
wesley encore au moins une année
c'est vrai que c'était drôle
la maison qu'on détruit qu'on a remis en
état d'ailleurs pas avec la même équipe
la maison qu'on a des trucs se trouve à
maisons laffitte et donc au début on n'a
pas eu les autorisations de tournage
s'est scindé le député maire de maisons
laffitte c'est chaque milliard pour la
non non ce milieu mais bien hard way
voilà mon bref il nous donne pas les
autorisations et grâce à claude berri on
les obtient il nous dit il edit il fait
à la production il dit voilà je veux
rencontrer dany boon en tournée pendant
un mois la balle et je veux je veux
rencontrer d'un niveau de jeu dit non
maintenant je travaille j'ai pas le
temps ça ça m'intéresse pas et puis non
non non non et la production de 10
insiste en disant ça serait mieux qu'ils
viennent parce qu'il a finalement
accepté qu'on tourne dans sa ville c'est
vrai c'est sympa et puis voilà il n'a
qu'à venir pendant l'heure du déjeuner
ça dure une heure et après voilà déjà
avec lui il est très sympathique et
items beaucoup
bon j d'accord donc il arrive juste en
train de travailler g on dit bonjour
monsieur myard voilà je termine puis on
lui dit voilà on est pause déjeuner on
va à la cantine est sur le chemin de la
cantine il tourne vers moi qui me fais
vous fait quoi sur le sur le film
je suis dit mais je suis acteur j'ai
écrit tout ça et je réalise une ni deux
vous produisez aussi le juge produit
enfin en coproduction mais comme comme
moteur mais pas mais oui pourquoi il me
dit vous êtes claude berri
je te jure que c'est vrai
non je suis élu semoun
ce mardi
je me dis je suis elie semoun il me fait
au mais oui mais oui pardon il y excusez
moi
eh bien il me dit ça va pas fort en ce
moment avec dieudonné
je dis oui on s'est séparé on a un peu
des soucis veut faire de la politique un
comme vous c'est pas facile là c'est sûr
et on marche encore une part je lui
parle à elie semoun depuis un moment il
fait mais il est où dany boon
évident mais je vous le présenter et je
vois laurent gamelon donc oui qui fait
d'omettre
voilà qui est là où je fais dany
député maire jacques meyer qui veut dire
bonjour
jeudi discrètement que je fais lycée
moon qu'il est dany boon ça et il fait
un homonyme ou nous je vous adore depuis
longtemps bravo pour tout ce que vous
faites il lui dit à lui
sur ce je pense à zinedine soualem qui
est dans le film mais je vais vous
connaissez smaïn
on s'est retrouvés à table avec une
grande partie du show business français
une personne ne correspondait la bonne
personne l'a
dit m
et y avait juste sa secrétaire qui
veulent assise à côté de moi qui vois
qui était morte de trouille qui me
disait dans l'oreille
dominique ça va la promo nom va bien là
je te rassure et non non je suis est ce
qu'on pourrait dire de plus sur le
prince britannique est toujours sous
tranquillisants non je suis rassuré il
revient donc à mesure dominique apple
cannes c'est elle
moi je pars contre suis inquiet pour
l'avenir ah oui qu'est ce qu'on va
devenir darif c'est bien moi quand ces
programmes et à nos films de spectacles
qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va tous se
donner la mort
alors dany vous êtes quand même un
acteur maintenant assez reconnus parce
que dans ce joyeux noël et une
formidable j'étais nommé aux césar
ensuite il est la doublure de webber
avec gad elmaleh bientôt mon meilleur
ami de patrice leconte avec daniel
auteuil ça ça commence à exister un oui
oui c'est d'ailleurs la chance de
tourner qu'avec patrice leconte les de
donner la réplique à daniel auteuil
pendant trois mois et s est formé à un
très beau rôle en plus un très très beau
film je les vis gens pensent yael naim
et direct il n'est pas
bon mais je crois que il ya plus qu'une
chose à faire maintenant que vous êtes
un grand acteur dany boon c'est une
interview alain delon
pensez vous que le public aime dany boon
dany boon pense que le public aime dany
boon mais mais mais pas autant que dany
boon ne s'aiment et dany boon et le jour
où le public chemra autant que dany boon
sem le public sera ce que c'est qu'être
dany boon
pensez-vous de dany boon l'homme dany
boon pense que les femmes ont beaucoup
de chance que dany boon soit un homme
pour vous dany boon est synonyme de quoi
franchement je suis dany boon est très
déçue que thierry ardisson pose cette
question
pensez vous que dany boon sur le plus
grands comédiens français
dany boon est un grand comédien c'est
vrai renesas pas français et les
ch'timis ah oui vous pensez que dany
boon peut tout jouer dany boon ne pourra
jamais jouer dany boon c'est beaucoup
trop durs car il faut être dany boon et
en même temps être dany boon et jose
dany boon c'est impossible
dany boon a platement défoncé
est-ce que vous pensez que dany boon
laissera une trace dans le cinéma
français une trace de pneu oui
est ce que dany boon espère avoir
bientôt une rue à son nom
mais dany boon des attire ardisson
rentrer dany boon dans ton gps et tu
verras
est ce que dany boon est lui aussi une
star au japon dany boon est elle
effectivement était au japon récemment
avec un certain alain delon
et les japonais disait
je veux dire qui est cet homme à côté de
dany boon
paralysant après l'heure de jeu
ça sera le 7 juin c'est légal michèle
laroque jean reno
je fais mes
moi
ce soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carte conseil d'ami
c'est quoi c'est con parce que c'est que
quand
vous devez donner un conseil à maurice
barthélémy pour lui expliquer comment
faire avec judith godrèche
concept car vraiment elle est très bon
c'est le cas on va prendre une autre
mais il sait très bien faire et j'avais
très bien moelleux se passe bien mais
très très bien et voilà il monfils no
elle adore d'ailleurs c'est un super
beau père il a fait un très bon film en
plus papa ouais karch si vous devez nous
chanter les corons de pierre bachelet en
pleurant en pleurant tu connais les
corans oui bien sûr
qu'un bug sénat vote ya quelques heures
quel acteur
ono
jeetoo les coraux
les hommes
des videurs de fonds
merci
j'adore le sait
j'accueille en aux rebelles
[Musique]
bonsoir êtes rédacteur en chef à
l'express vous publiez avec une autre
journaliste de l'express qui s'appelle
laurence debril un document intitulé
people le grand déballage chez michel
lafon alors d'abord qu'est-ce qu'un
people mais beaucoup en attaque j'ai
l'impression c'est quelqu'un de connu en
vérité vous en êtes aussi je suis pour
le moins aussi un mois je suis un
mariole scénarios les plus folles
alors dans le prologue de votre livre
vous décrivez la reine marie-antoinette
comme la première people et c'est vrai
que c'est la première star à avoir fait
l'objet d'une d'une traque médiatique
oui parce que sa vie privée a été gâté
et pied décortiqué traquer qu'à l'époque
effectivement
on allait tous les matins à acheter de
damparis des billets qui étaient
manuscrit qui est elle est dite et
quelques centaines d'exemplaires sur
laquelle figuraient les détails de la
vie privée nantes honnête et sexuelles
conjugales domestique oui il y avait des
nouvelles du dû me royal et vous dites
dans votre livre ce serait absolument
impensable aujourd'hui qu'on donne au
sujet de sophie marceau je crois que
c'est l'exemple que vous prenez
on disait au sujet de marie-antoinette
madison de chambre aspecté effectuant la
couche entre guillemets notre de chaque
matin et on en faisait un détail
effectivement quitté manuscrits ensuite
est distribué dans paris quelques heures
après ça a été les premiers magazines de
l'époque en vérité oui c'est la première
finalement avoir été victime du commerce
du ragot de travail ou alors vous êtes à
quai le bouquin par un événement
considérable c'est la fameuse affaire
cécilia sarkozy donc c'est la première
fois dit vous en france que la vie
privée d'un homme politique de premier
plan et jeté en pâture aux médias
en août 2005 paris match publie des
photos de cécilia sarkozy et richard
attias ce à new york et vous préciser
que c'est la deuxième meilleure vente de
l'année 2005 après la mort du peuple ne
mendie pas dans paris match mais ça pour
vous c'est quelque chose sur lui son
enfant depuis 40 ans il ya 40 ans on se
souvient quand même que le couple
pompidou avait fait l'objet à l'époque
ouais mais rudement nauséabonde que la
presse d'extrême retenue reprise
largement d'ailleurs et c'est la
première fois que la vie privée dans une
politique et traquer ce point là c'est
vraiment eu six mois de traque
effectivement et sarkozy sa vie privée
quand même le dessus ont été pillés
épiée traquée de manière assez assez
assez étonnante et ça a été une grande
première effectivement mieux alors quand
cécilia revient en janvier 2006 rtl
annonçait un communiqué c'est absolument
incroyable c'est nouveau et en fait les
retrouvailles entre cécilia sarkozy et
nicolas sarkozy donne lieu à un numéro
spécial de vsd ne visait qu'à fait
trois-quatre cover de match qu'on a fait
quelques unes également la presse people
effectivement a fait ses choux gras ça
et il ya eu en vérité deux à trois
millions d'exemplaires qui sont vendus
sur cette affaire-là donc ce que vous
décrivez en tous les cas dans votre
bouquin c'est cette peopolisation du
politique et garde et chirac par exemple
qui va parler de sa fille anorexique
laurence chez fogiel ce qui est
absolument impensable c'était impensable
de 10 ou 15 ans aujourd'hui où plus
aucun tabou cloud qu'ils limitent plus
qu une pudeur je crois que chacun y va
on l'a vu ces jours ci avec le couple
strauss kahn sinclair qui a la foi dans
paris match sur tf1 qui jusqu'ici
n'avait jamais mis sa vie privée quand
tout cas de cette manière là sur la
table et qui sont plus aucune pudeur le
fait aujourd'hui c'était impensable
encore une fois il ya dix ou quinze un
jack lang qui annonce sa candidature à
la candidature dans voici son récit
c'est incroyable
mais c'est vrai quand tu lis un bouquin
c'est assez assez assez passé totalement
inaperçu mais c'est vrai que lang a été
le premier homme politique français il a
fait la démarche est une manière très
ostensible il a annoncé effectivement sa
connection en voici la barre d'un gala
la semaine prochaine
deux dans playboy de lui
alors ça marche très très bien à la
presse people ces trois millions
d'exemplaires par semaine ces 12
millions d'hectares wifaq personnes et
wallace + 50 % 15 ans il ya des projets
de presse en préparation il ya deux
journaux qui vont sortir au mois de
septembre donc c'est un marché
exponentiel
exponentielle personne ne s'y attendait
quand closer est sorti en 2005 sur le
marché tout le monde a souri ça a été un
boom fabuleux ray sept cent mille
exemplaires au moment de la faire perdre
aux acquêts rappelez-vous alors même la
presse non pipoles 6 mai le magazine
pour lequel vous vous travaillez
l'express fait sa couverture sur la
séropositivité de
charlotte valandrey c'est quand même
assez ça nous a surpris à l'époque mais
on l'avait fait je pense avec beaucoup
de dignité de et de pudeur aussi parce
que le pape y était joliment écrit mais
ça a été un succès c'est un succès il
c'est vrai que l'on peut difficilement
passer à côté de l'histoire comme ça là
aussi pourquoi l'express le président
aujourd'hui alors qu'effectivement les
français les gens adorent ça pour peu
qu'on le fasse encore une fois dans la
dignité et avec un peu de sobriété un
peu d'écriture pourquoi pas
alors vous raconter la collusion entre
les pipoles et la presse people c'est
très intéressant il ya ceux qui
réécrivent leur interview alors à gianni
par exemple réécrit cette interview est
déjà arrivé en tout cas demain certains
politiques le font aussi est arrivé tu
réécris des interviews nommage les jeux
les recopie
avec un tapis calque toi
tu ne vis pas moi non plus je dis pas et
toitures et écrites des interviews
parfois j'aurais aimé avoir l'occasion
de le faire non c'est la liberté de la
presse on peut pas réécrire ses
interviews maintenant c'est vrai que
souvent ils proposent sont sortis du
contexte et souvent on aimerait pouvoir
le faire souvent les journalistes
écrivent une interview parce qu'ils
essayent de compiler toutes les infos
ils font les phrases qu'on peut rien à
voir exactement qui sont vidés de sens
il ya ceux qui réécrivent des interviews
fectivement comme adjani dites-vous et
puis il ya ceux qui changent
complètement ce qu'ils ont dit ce qu'ils
représentent sarkozy un jour on lui file
interwiew il dit moi j'en ai rien à
[__] du psg je regarde pas les
émissions de variétés à la télé après il
se rend compte que c'est quand même pas
terrible donc ils corrigent l'interview
il dit j'adore le psg et puis je regarde
toutes les émissions de santé diabète et
d
extraordinaire cessons de nous inviter
des propos qui les conseillent aux lions
dit mais c'est pas possible il a réécrit
effectivement la réponse c'est
incroyable il ya bruel aussi dit vous
qui êtes allés au montage de fréquences
tard oui mais bruel quelqu'un qui fait
très attention à la france son image et
sa communication il vérifie tout
d'ailleurs c'est plutôt une qualité dans
le détail y compris dans les photos de
lui qui sont punis à la presse people
dans paris match ou ailleurs celui même
qui choisit les photos il voit dans
l'action il suit la mise en page c'est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement mais titulaire
sa vie privée mais est-ce que la sortie
ça c'est petit spa complètement le
personnage sans doute mais en même temps
ça protège parce que c'est vrai qu'il
fait partie des gens comme m qui de tout
temps n'ont jamais été écornée par la
presse people parce que comme johnny
hallyday d'ailleurs qui ont toujours
fait très attention à leur image depuis
30 ou 40 ans pour johnny en tout cas et
leur style assez que leur image est
intacte et qu'ils ont toujours fait très
attention dans une question oui y'a
janvier a permis à l'or lui vous dites
c'est terrible parce qu'en fait il a été
pris à partie par la presse people quand
il eu d'histoire avec sa femme histoire
incroyable marquer mais il me dit qu'il
était dans une convention de toyota avec
une voiture siglée closer oui
ok c'était juste un garçon qui était un
peu d'hémiplégie parce que il a fait
tout et son contraire dans sa vie il a
attaqué la presse people il ay là il a
fait 45 ans et en diffamation à l'été
dernier par voie signal à vis des autres
journaux qu'il avait effectivement salma
attaqué il a eu de raison de le faire il
parce que effectivement il a vécu cet
été de manière très difficile en
revanche c'est quelqu'un qui dans sa vie
a toujours négocié un vendu vendu entre
guillemets à la fois son image sa vie
privée avant et après d'un côté
effectivement il a beaucoup attaqué la
presse people et de l'autre il en a vécu
comme entraîneur j'aimerais donc c'est
une c'est une c'est une ambiguïté
absolue il n'est pas le seul dans ce
métier d'un virus mutant secteur et puis
est ce comme johnny hallyday avec qui a
jamais de problème c'est un miracle
absolu le maghreb parce que ça fait
qu'ils sont quarante ans encore une fois
que ce garçon en vérité n'a jamais été
vraiment attaquer pour la presse il est
respecté par ce métier ou très peu très
très faible a été bien sûr qu'il a été
lynché 40 ans heureusement bien sûr on
oublie vite les choses heureusement
doute oui mais il a une très belle image
de la presse quand même le respecte en
général en général quand même s'il a de
bonnes relations avec la peau street il
a l'habitude en tout cas mais parce qu
il la gère extrêmement bien je crois
qu'il est bien entouré il connaît bien
ce métier connaît bien les photographes
il connaît bien ces professions et je
crois que que tout ça finit par payer
corriger les comptes il est quand même
assez épargné s'est pendu mais vous
dites alors johnny s'est tu payes je
pose un la naissance d'adoption me le
fait le disque la guyane et milan hejduk
et organise lit le fait avec beaucoup de
deux de ses plats ça c'est que s'ils ne
posent pas toutes les façons ce volet
ouais mon kiné et autant poser que ça
soit contrôlée plutôt que voler que ça
ce qui s'apprête à j'ai bien tout
compris le fait dans toute transparence
tout le monde le sait lui-même le
revendiquer il affiche et je crois que
c'est là c'est la bonne démarche oui ce
que j'avais à dire c'est peut-être la
meilleure solution c'est absolument
ouais bah oui comme servante et c'est un
peu faustien quoi
comme la star ac
alors très intéressant aussi dans votre
bouquin vous dites qui alimentent la
presse pipole alors il ya d'abord les
pipots le même qui font passer des les
infos du pipeau le men ne soit
compliquant tout compris on vous ressort
de ce marché dont qui on joue qui
alimente beaucoup une très grande part
effectivement si on devait encore envie
de quitter sa femme par exemple qui
s'est photographiée avec sa maîtresse
comme ça c'est trop qu'il a pas fallu
annoncer quoi je sais pas c'est que
justement vous savez que c'est arrivé
ouais il ya l'entourage les jantes
ouvrage contre ces petits monsieur ans
et elle évite par exemple que loana
c'est sa propre mère qui a vendu à paris
match les photos du bébé oui parce que
les familles sont souvent effectivement
très active lui-même elles doivent
également les descendu à solliciter sa
main ouais bien sûr elle n'a pas fait de
ce moment son produit et puis les gens
fragiles qui qui qui sait elle
facilement se seront tues moi je sais
pas quand il ya beaucoup d'argent en jeu
à chaque fois c'est souvent ils sont des
gens des fois des gens dans des milliers
c'est simple et c'est vrai que quand
même le mirage de ce miroir l'accord est
facile et puis à les apporteurs
d'affaires les qui touchent des
commissions plus évoqué notamment le cas
de star beaucoup ils sont tous encore
une fois de l'entourage les entourages
et alors il ya la nouvelle hantise des
pipoles c'est les sna paradis le
portable ouais le portal enfin c'est
terrible ça c'est terrible incendie
jamais trahi de coke kate moss
quitta plus haut absolu oui parce que
s'est tenue avant moi
danger absolu aujourd'hui n'importe qui
peut prendre une photo de n'importe qui
sera sur un trottoir le balancer sur
internet dans la foulée way où le vent
dans un journal ce qui a été proposé
avec se pressent à plusieurs reprises je
me souviens nous on nous a contacté un
jour c'est un garçon qui était à cannes
c'était un jeune garçon qui a un
portable ils nous proposaient des photos
de cécilia sarkozy à l'époque ouais et
on les a pas acheté bien sûr mais ça
c'est très fréquent menons aujourd'hui
les journaux sont submergés de
propositions de 2,2 de jean total -
denain qui vendent effectivement tout
tout
à la fois sur le net et dans la presse
par ailleurs oui mais j'étais read dead
people alors parce que maintenant on
peut plus énervé dans un aéroport et
voient une torture c'est un peu près
bien vrai danger c'est que d'imiter des
stars aujourd'hui qu'ils étaient
protégés va devenir un frigo absolue
mouais bah oui ça va être terrible alors
bien un truc quand même qui est encore
plus grave dans la fabrication de la
pipoleries là c'est ce qui s'est passé
sur la star ac 5 entre mode et jérémy
dire que vous dites maintenant peu
importe la véracité de ce qu'on raconte
c'est à dire que tout le monde sait que
c'est faux que c'est bidon que c'est
monté mais c'est pas grave seule compte
la satisfaction du plaisir immédiat oui
c'est mon bidonnage absolue ouais c'est
un métier qui fait sur vos consoles on
regarde plus la seule chose qui importe
c'est la photo c'est une zac scène et le
reste est entièrement général scénarisé
il truc très compliqué de trouver la
vérité dans tout cela et puis voilà puis
à l'argent aussi que les procès rapporte
aux pipots la stéphanie de monaco vous
dites quand même 3 millions d'euros de
dommages et intérêts en 15 ans atteint
pour lui si le oui c'est plus beau
pactole oui enfin elle en avait besoin
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas besoin
c'est moral ça finit bien
déjà fait des procès à des journaux toi
ah oui messieurs et alors quand on a été
pris en photo il ya l'avocat on voit un
pacte et bleu pour prévenir qu'on sait
qu'on a été pris en photo et pour dire
ne ne publiez pas sinon il y aura procès
en général ça ça il publie pas donc on
attend pas qu'ils publient et puis on
nous a proposé est plein de trucs moi on
m'a proposé on nous a proposé d'acheter
notre mariage ça aurait largement
couvert les frais cachés
du mousseux
et champomy on a bu bout et de la
clairette de die et mais voilà on l'a on
l'a pas fait moi quand je me suis fait
attaquer sur l'autoroute oh là là je
m'en souviens de satisloh quelle horreur
et hebinger j'avais un bon combat
j'avais neuf points de suture fin
j'étais menacé puisque j'ai récupéré mon
chien dans les voitures bref ben on m'a
appelé en urgence et labrador qui gueule
dans les loges c'est ce que
moi je m'étais fait attaquer par des
faux policiers qui m'ont arrêté sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence et les la vraie
police n'arrête pas sur la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence donc je savais pas que la
police en fait elle emmène jusqu'à une
aire de repos ou 1 voilà où une station
donc je voulais faire passer le message
comme quoi fallait pas s'arrêter donc
j'ai fait 1 1
comment l interview pour paris match
mais sans photo mais on m'a proposé de
faire la couverture de match de vsd de
tous les journaux avec ma gueule amoché
quoi donc je vois là j'ai pas fait mais
ne t'a pas fait de procès s'ils n'ont
jamais c'est allé très loin quoi mais je
vais quand même c'est prendre en photo
avec notre fils en tramway
mais bon j'ai le papier bleu ça marche
bien je crois que les îles et people
sont très peu protégés finalement et
encore plus aujourd'hui avec avec les
portables et tout ça c'est pas très
sympa cette histoire laissez pas moral
pas ce qu'ils vont dans les soirées se
faire offrir des portables ils seront
épiés par des portages de vrai
[Musique]
jamais le procès avec la presse 6 à 6,6
avec voici un pas uniquement voici
public
est là dedans
ça va pas tarder
ouais dans tous les cas ils s'en foutent
là vous dites dans votre bouquin renaud
revel que les procès par exemple pour
voici ça représente 2 % du chiffre
d'affaires oui c'est finalement c'est
très original
donc même limite us où il rencontre
aussi je crie et en même temps il ya des
people qui font des procès qui sont des
bouteilles par exemple ou poivre d'arvor
c'est arrivé mais carole bouquet pour
valeur voire quelques uns parce qu'à
force d'en faire effectivement les juges
au 6e comment ça quand même attendre un
peu le nez il ya certaines juridictions
qui font très attention à ce qu'ils les
voient défilent à longueur d'année donc
au bout du moment où du 15e 20e procès
il dit stop donc on regarde de plus près
ouais donc guère certains effectivement
certains clients entre guillemets qui ne
touche pas tous les toits
alors vous raconter évidemment le pire
c'est les people qui sont payés pour les
pour les soirées c'est celui de three
classique avec classique mais cher quand
même de 9 53 mille euros en liquide dans
les toilettes du majestic les toilettes
hommes ou femmes c'est important pour la
super fête devant les flics à l'époque
elle est totale pour la faire khelifa un
avis c'est terrible depardieu dans le
par dieu c'est leur lovelock qui avait
été posé sur le sur la tablette de son
avion quoi
dans un vol paris nice depardieu 30000
euros et man afin que celle aux
toilettes j'ai dû laisser 2 euros
on assiste à une théâtre au cra si oui
parce que aujourd'hui tout est spectacle
tout et people
chacun effectivement avance une image
pardonnez moi mais c'est pas vous qui
êtes encore du tout mais la moindre star
aujourd'hui grandi à la star academy
wire devient une vedette en l'espace
d'un instant de quelques secondes
quelques minutes quelques calculs
quelques jours extraordinaires dans
votre bouquin quand vous racontez par
exemple que jennifer lopez et ben
affleck
ils ont plus rapporté à la presse pipole
avec les papiers qui a eu sur eux que ce
qu'ils ont rapporté aux producteurs du
film amours troubles c'est quelqu'un
qu'on fait c'est énorme ça quand même
quand même alors que les stars des
années 50 il avait une vie privée très
caché un sens avait rien d'eux et il y
avait une magie un mystère et maintenant
faut qu'on vous faut tout savoir c'est
vrai c'est et les questions souvent des
gens ristourne sur le sur les choses
très personnelles autre
est pas ici
c'est beau le grand déballage c'est
publié chez michel lafon mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
l'orage vous laisser filer merci d'avoir
été avec nous
j'accueille tarak ben ammar et armés maï
chine
[Musique]
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on est
très flattée évidemment de vous recevoir
vie vous êtes un énorme producteurs vous
aussi tarak traque vous êtes l'héritier
de la dynastie ben ammar qui a longtemps
été associé c'est sarah que j'avais star
ac' bénin
quelle honte en aient été associés aux
destinées de l'état tunisien vous est le
neveu de l'épousé de bourguiba vous avez
commencé après études à rome comme comme
assistant de production le matin vous
vous levier pour aller voir si les le
plein des voitures était fait quoi vous
êtes vraiment commencer en bas ensuite
vous avez emmené d'orge lukasz en
tunisie
georges locas pour la guerre des étoiles
il n'avait pas d'argent et je disais oui
à tous les metteurs en scène de quelle
que soit leur nationalité une tunisie
encore pauvre et qui était rentré dans
le monde de tourisme et je rencontre
georges occase en aéroport et il me dit
est ce que tu as un décor pour une
planète toute manière je disais oui par
principe qu il n en tunisie une fois
qu'ils étaient là je me démerde ai
trouvés les corps et la planète de la
guerre des étoiles le premier je vous
parle dire exactement 30 ans je les
remets dans un village qui s'appelle
tataouine ray et la planète tatooine
pour les milliards de fans c'est un
petit village dans le sud tunisien qui a
beaucoup plu à giorgio cassin et depuis
je rejoue castres vient tourner même un
plan parce que ça lui porte bonheur il
vient tourner tous les plans de la
guerre des étoiles de la planète
tataouine même s'il fait le film
ailleurs comme ça a été le cas l'an dia
ensuite tard que j'avais beaucoup donné
avec avec jésus vous avez produit jésus
de nazareth de zeffirelli la vie de
brian des monty python
13h45 avant jésus-christ de jean yanne
et vous avez distribué le film de mel
gibson la passion du christ j'ai vu
aussi des échecs vous avez du pirate de
polanski qui est une catastrophe pour
vous vous avez perdu combien tarak le
dessus au 20 20 25 millions de dollars
presque autant que moi un peu moins je
voulais rentrer dans les toilettes
mais je les ai récupérées ouais grâce à
un procès historique c'est la première
fois dans l'histoire du cinéma qu'un
producteur étranger de surcroît du
tiers-monde j'ai fait un procès à la
grande major company universal away qui
a duré dix ans et j'ai gagné parce qu'il
m'avait signé un contrat qu'ils n'ont
pas respectées c'est pour ça que j'ai
perdu et l'argent et preuve de la grande
démocratie américaine j'ai gagné devant
un jury populaire
19 millions de dollars bravo
[Applaudissements]
très réussie avec la télévision où vous
êtes associé de berlusconi avec murdoch
avec patrick le lay et tf1 le cinéma
vous êtes associé à l'exil au dollar
anticipe maintenant avec les frères
weinstein dans leur nouvelle société qui
l'ont créée après leur départ de miramax
alors vous avez vous êtes l'un des deux
frères weinstein légendes d'hollywood
producteur et distributeur alors
allons-y de pulp fiction reservoir dogs
kill bill sexe mensonges et vidéo cinéma
paradiso la leçon de piano adieu ma
concubine la cité de dieu shakespeare in
love game the new york des aviateurs le
patient anglais sur l'herbe scary movie
les invasions barbares et sin city
[Musique]
alors vous arrivés tous les deux de
cannes du festival de cannes vous avez
trouvé comment le festival harvey
iphone fait face je trouvais que le
festival était absolument formidable
jeu les jurys ont fait un excellent
choix bien oui mais c'est la seule
décision avec laquelle j'étais pas
d'accord
trouvé que c'était prennent à la cause
que réduites au meilleur rôle féminin
toute seule elle n'avait pas besoin de
tout tout cet aéropage femina autour d
harvey vous avez déclaré pour moi le
meilleur film réalisé sur los angeles si
chinatown de polanski le meilleur film
réalisé sur new york c'est macadam
cowboy de john schlesinger le meilleur
film de gangsters sait il était une fois
en amérique de sergio leone tous ces
réalisateurs sont venues d'europe il
faut défendre la diversité culturelle en
europe c'est rare de la part d'un
producteur américain entendre ça
et vous voyez vous
moi je crois beaucoup à la diversité
culturelle mais en plus il s'agit par le
passé je le répèterai il me semble que
la france et d'autres pays doivent
justement protéger leur cinéma contre
justement le cinéma américain même si
moi je suis américain joue 10 à ross à
main pourquoi parce que les américains
ne rend pas honneur aux français n'a pas
des télés avec des émissions françaises
et pourtant l'inversé vrai qu'on n'a pas
présenté de films français en tant que
fille ni à la télévision en prime time
depuis 40 ans alors comment où est la
justice où l'équité par rapport aux
français l'onglet ou encore au cinéma
allemand ou espagnol a aucune justice là
dedans moi j'adore le cinéma quand
j'avais 10 ans
j'entrais dans un cinéma chez les voir
ce film les 400 coups de françois
truffaut shrek c'était un film érotique
parce que le titre blood for a le blues
la traduction de 400 coups ça faisait
penser au blowjobs au pipe alors on a
fait quatre des kilomètres sous la neige
pour aller voir ce film il ya que mon
frère et moi qui avons vu ce film parce
que tout le monde était déçu c'est un
film en noir et blanc avec des sous
titres pas une seule équipe enfin
toujours est il que huit de mes copains
ont quitté le cinéma en cours en disant
allez vous faire voir les bob et moi on
est resté et on est tombé amoureux du
cinéma français ce jour-là l'âge de 10
ans avec le film de truffaut riz c'est
une mission dans le monde et
principalement
dans la banlieue de new york votre père
s'appelait max il était jam en terre il
vous a mené tous les samedis au cinéma
il aimait tous les genres sauf les films
de guerre parce qu'ils avaient combattu
pendant la guerre il fallait plus en
parler de la guerre se joue c'est
exactement ça en effet mon frère et moi
on adorait les films d'errol flynn qui
sauve l amérique mais mon père ne
pouvait pas supporter ces crimes de
guerre il ya un film qui pour moi à tout
et mystifier s'était il faut sauver le
soldat ryan pourquoi parce que jusqu'à
ce que je voie ce film je ne comprenais
pas ce que mon père a à z mais mon père
avait vu justement de la guerre il avait
participé à des batailles et c'est pour
ça qu'ils pouvaient pas voir de film de
guerre à moins qu'il ne dise la vérité
est très peu de films d'hollywood de
présenter la réalité on en faisait tout
à un film de propagande autour de
l'amérique mais on voyait jamais du sens
et les pas ne tuaient jamais personne ce
n'était pas vraiment la vision réelle de
la guerre en votre mère s'appelle myriam
elle est toujours vivante et elle pense
encore que le cinéma est un job
occasionnels et vous dit qu'elle n'a pas
encore perdu espoir que vous deveniez
médecin
mais à 81 ans et c'est quelqu'un a
besoin d'une bonne mère juive elle est
là pour ça elle peut vérifier les les
venues aux jeux olympiques pour la
discipline je me plains de tout et
c'était et s'il ya quelqu'un qui a un
souci elle peut se faire du souci pour
tout le monde en 1979 vous montez avec
votre frère une société qui s'appelle
miramax du nom de vos parents myriam et
max voilà et alors vous allez au
festival de cannes au début des années
80 vous n'avez pas d'argent vous
connaissez personne et vous êtes dans un
placard à balais à l'hôtel majestic
c'était après keira palais et j'ai dormi
avec mon frère
parce que sinon il y aurait eu toutes
sortes de rumeurs à mon sujet personne
ne m'a habité avant est filmé dans le
palais des festivals a fait
la précision qui celle que je suis
infiltré comme on faisait un mot clé non
rentrées par les portes de sortie par
les issues de secours et en os ici
j'essaie sur les marchés puis les
gendarmes sont venus le pizza
celui qui était juste à côté de moi qui
était sur
le chemin tranquille
c'était une connerie en personne
qui nous aider j'en ai alors c'est un
effort monsieur bond a dit bon nous on
les sait rester dans la salle et c'était
la première fois que j'ai rencontré sean
connery et 20 ans plus tard j'ai raconté
cette histoire lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur
de lui présenter un film dans le cadre
du film festival de new york et je suis
raconté l'anecdote il a beaucoup ri
parce que c'est le genre de personne
qu'il est
décidément trop qui
[Musique]
alors voilà donc en 1981 arrive in sync
et son premier festival de cannes et dix
ans plus tard dans un autre festival de
sundance organisé par robert redford
vous repérez sexe mensonges et vidéo des
soderbergh et c'est le début du succès
vous inventez le blockbuster sur le film
qui marche indépendant
ah oui
je sais pas si j'ai inventé ce ce genre
moi il me semble que un grand film a
besoin d'être
confiné aux ghettos des films d'art et
essai sexe mensonges et vidéo on peut le
voir dans le monde entier il fallait pas
le confiner aux petites salles le fait
qu'un film soit intelligent ne
signifiait pas qu'il soit limité c'est
les mauvais films qui devraient être
limitées mais les films intelligents
devrait avoir un large public au
contraire alors votre autre grande
spécialité harvey c'est la course aux
oscars
vous dépenser des millions de dollars en
publicité en soirée spéciale en cadeau
s'emparer des coups de fil avec un
acharnement au delà du réel pour avoir
des oscars vous promettez aux acteurs
que s'ils travaillent que vont avoir la
petite statuette dorée
soi qui est 250 domination elle se joue
l ça venait one quelque soixante et onze
oscars
alors oui ça l'est pour moi
l'académie les oscars c'est la façon de
commercialiser un rhum finance donc
évidemment on a investi beaucoup de
temps et d'efforts là dedans mais
quelquefois il ya un petit film comme le
son piano ou
shakespeare in love ou le patient mais
n'auraient normalement pas trouvé un
grand public à travers le monde mais
c'est évidemment l'oscar qui était le
tremplin qui leur a permis d'accord sur
la table alors pas simplement pas
nécessairement meilleur film mais aussi
mon meilleur rôle masculin au féminin
évidemment ça aide énormément un film
l'année prochaine hors vous avez
d'afrique à jouer marianne côtier qui a
joué cap j'ai vu 20 minutes de ce film à
cannes et sa prestation je suis sûr
qu'elle mériterait un oscar en tout cas
elle sera nominée cotillard dans la vie
devient le piaf ont réalisé par olivier
dahan est produit par ilan goldman alors
on vous reproche quand même harvey un
certain irrespect pour les oeuvres ont
dit que vous coupez que vous remonter
les files les français dit vous vous
appelle d'artagnan à cause du sabre et
on vous appelle aussi six organs harvey
s'est voué à une guerre des chefs de
chaleur après l'émission je vais vous
montrer la version de cinq heures de
genk the new york et vous comprendrez
mec et s'il vous arrivait à tenir trois
heures chapeau à
le plus grand honneur que j'ai reçu
c'est que martin scorsese dit maintenant
que les la version de deux heures et
demie est la seule verso qu'il
présentera donc lui on est contents il
n'y a que la concurrence qui m'accusent
d'être crn ce parce qu'ils sont jaloux
mais nous nous misons la vérité et en
disant la vérité en face nous emportons
les palmes dans les oscars il a
l'habitude de dire la vérité alors c'est
vrai pour un metteur en scène quand on
lui dit son film est long 1
c'est difficile c'est difficile et les
metteurs en scène sont entourés de
collaborateurs qui n'osent pas harry est
un peu brusque mais souvent essentiels
alors il faut s'habituer à tort il
écoperait aux états unis vous savez
conteste les films sur des publics
cliniques privées hosting pluvieux avant
de les sortir et on apprend beaucoup et
malheureusement il a souvent raison
c'est à dire que la conclusion du public
c'est un peu ce qui l'a anticipé mais il
le fait à la fin avec la collaboration
des metteurs en scène des producteurs
est ce que est ce que patrice chéreau
est content de la version courte de la
reine margot vous avez distribué aux
états unis
qu'il est très satisfait je
crois que la seule chose qui a empêché
le film d'être un peu plus grands succès
encore c'est que john était censé venir
en amérique pour faire la promotion or
elle avait des problèmes personnels n'a
pas besoin c'était
c'était une déception que les appels ne
puisse pas venir mais toutes les
critiques étaient très bonne sur la
reine margot et on estime que c'est l'un
des grands films français états unis et
c'est la version courte
mais il a dit qu'il était très content
de voir ce film
pour lui en tant que juif il trouvait
que c'était un soulagement de voir des
protestants des cats a dit constituant
trop coûteux que d'avoir des des juifs
qui se font assassiner c'était un très
relaxant alors on vous reproche aussi
d'être terriblement dur en affaire
harvey il ya une phrase qui courent sur
vous à hollywood qui dit si vous ne vous
êtes jamais fait baiser par miramax si
vous n'avez jamais travaillé avec eux
haiping payton et leur game heroes alors
là encore ceux qui disent ça
généralement se cachent derrière
l'anonymat
ce qui est bien souvent ce sont des gens
qui n'ont pas de succès est ce que vous
avez lu le nom de l'auteur de cette
citation la
ja que les lâches qui diront des choses
pareilles en 1993 ou vendait donc à
disney la société miramax
ce qui s'est passé
c'est que tous les metteurs en scène
on découvrait tout le talent mais nous
n'avions pas les moyens malgré notre
succès nous n'étions quand même une
petite maison de production donc
personne qui a réalisé my left foot nous
a quittés pour aller à une berceau parce
que nous y opposer mieux alors
évidemment on aurait proposé davantage
si vous n'avez pu mais nous ne pouvions
pas d'eau quand nous nous sommes rendus
à dézoner ils ont décidé de nous donner
les moyens de travailler avec ces
réalisateurs is hot et très bien au
départ des sept premières années de la
collaboration avec disney ont été
excellentes on a fait pour fonctionner
ils se sont un peu mêler de ça mais
disons que on pouvait naviguer assez
bien et on a fait tourner sporting n'a
fait beaucoup de films très controversé
mais après documents et fahrenheit nine
eleven où ils ont refusé lord of the
rings bon là ça a commencé à mal tourner
disney vous a refusé le seigneur des
anneaux
j'avais développé un projet avec peter
jackson
j'ai mis 10 millions de dollars pour
développer toute la technologie
des dommages en nouvelle-zélande pour
pouvoir faire ce que vous avez vu à
l'écran les trois scénarios ont été
développés par nous j'allais voir
des images et des piles de jackson ou
faire un film il nous faut 180 millions
$ parce que j'avais un plafond je
pouvais pas aller au delà de 75 millions
c'est tout ce que je peux dépenser quand
j'étais aux commandes et j'aurais dit il
m'en faut plus je voulais faire trois
ont dit non non seulement on n'y croyait
pas seigneur des anneaux mais ils m'ont
dit je conserverai une partie des
recettes en tant que producteur veut
garder des sous qu'est-ce que vous n'y
croyez pas et c'est comme ça que font
qu'on sera franchie donc ça plus faranah
est le film de michael moore vous avez
quittez donc votre association avec
disney ils ont produit
fahrenheit qui a gagné à cannes michael
moore et disney a refusé de le
distribuer parce que il attaqué bien sûr
le président bush son frère et lui ont
sorti un chèque ont payé le film l'ont
acheté
quelle erreur pour disney et l'on
distribue dans le monde entier avec le
succès que vous connaissez courageux
alors que l'écouté donc votre
association avec disney et vous avez
monté une nouvelle société qui s'appelle
the weinstein company à vous disposez
d'un milliard de dollars on se laisse
rêveur soit pour faire des films ils ont
un milliard de dollars évitant le cinéma
quand même ils seront lever un milliard
de dollars donc associé avec tarak ben
ammar c'est assez beau d'ailleurs de
voir le juif de brooklyn qui était
associé avec le le musulman de de tunis
est assez joli l'histoire 1 c'est la
bible c'est la bible avec vous il ya des
français il ya des européens il ya tf1
il ya patrick le lay qui est associé
avec vous il ya lvmh aussi qui est
associé avec vous c'était ses voix la
cce cuménique finalement et des japonais
un chinois un c'est vraiment une
compagnie internationale est très
européenne
tout en étant américaine avec bob est
ravi qu'ils détiennent 50% de la
compagnie à 50 ou 51 51
or voilà donc parmi les premiers films
de cette société y en a un qui s'appelle
yang hannibal le jeune hannibal qui est
impliqué l de la fameuse série du
silence des agneaux avec gaspard ulliel
alors c'est très gonflé d'avoir pris
gaspard ulliel
mais ça c'est la dp2 tara qu'un ces
luttes la découverte sur le terrain
qu'en tant que producteur du film
l'année dernière à cannes m'a présenté
un casting avec passe pas cinq minutes
aux questions qu'ils avaient été
tous les acteurs américains plus quand
nous voulait se roule quand j'ai vu ce
casting c'est absolument extraordinaire
ce garçon ra très très loin
il est rien incarnation de anthony
hopkins mais le courage de ravi c'est de
confier parce que le film sortira dans
3500 salles le 9 février aux états unis
dans le monde entier c'est la première
fois qu'un budget de cette importance
est confiée à un jeune acteur français
oui absolument ça c'est gas major
company ouais même avec le test de gaz
paru elle ne m'aurait pas suivi parce
qu'ils auraient dit comment on va le
promouvoir un service et comment le
promouvoir et pour l'histoire
naturellement c'est pourquoi anthony
hopkins est devenu un électeur donc
c'est la vie du jeune hannibal et on
expliquera on ne dira pas ici pourquoi
il est devenu moi je le sais bien donc
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble alors
vous allez regarder tous les deux votre
caméra c'est le cal rouge de caméra wi
de red light of day and you say you say
just magnéto serge magnéto serge
[__] one two three
[Musique]
voilà bien des balles le jeune hannibal
c'est l'avis de hannibal lecter quand il
était jeune et pourquoi il est devenu
hannibal lecter alors remis trac nous a
dit tout à l'heure que vous disiez
toujours la vérité donc on va voir on va
faire une interview hollywood suisse ait
entre basique in sting t2 et
marie-antoinette lequel vous détestez le
plus
il ya 1,5 tout ça c'est le le plus
horrible des deux c'est incroyablement
mauvais mais voilà rien connaître à
quand même des très bonnes choses dedans
oui mais qu'est ce que sofia coppola
doit encore apprendre
à sofia coppola est une bonne mais
réalisatrice elle avait cette vision la
critique n'a pas suivi mais le public
semble l'avoir suivie jusque au mans
mais le fait de comparer marie
antoinette et badiane 5 2 un des plus
mauvais films jamais réalisés au coût de
là du pire
si vous voyez ce film
l'argent devrait aller
vous voulez la vérité à
part ça ça m'a bien plu harvick est ce
que vous n'aimez pas à hollywood
allez-vous d'être un club fermé
moi je me suis dit ce serait plutôt
comme rome à l'époque ancienne il
fallait être spartacus en quelque sorte
pour déclencher une révolte
que vous avez les grosses médor il est
si gros studios qui sont identiques mais
qui s'intéresse davantage à l'argent
et ça n'est qu'une question d'argent de
grossesse alors si les gens disent qu'on
est dur c'est eux qui nous ont entre 6
et des studios qui nous ont endurci et
le fait que ce soit dur c'est ça qui
nous a permis de les combattre parce
qu'attention avant lui personne ne
pouvait rivaliser avec les yeux des
petits réalisateur et se dessine à
sochaux écrasés maintenant ils ont plus
pouvoir parce que nous avons été dur
quel est l'acteur hollywood qui mérite
plus 20 millions de dollars par film
la plupart dont
qu'est ce que les français font mieux
que les américains au cinéma
français ont un cinéma plus intime plus
personnel
le spectateur voit son intelligence
flatter c'était les acteurs sont
intelligents personnage de scénario et
c'est d'être à tes jambes et on n'est
pas content et son nom par rapport au
public c'est qu'on relève le niveau
alors qu'arrive ou pour attirer un
maximum de public on nivelle par le bas
alors que france ma tendance à d'étendre
notre sens et les comédiens sont très
souvent en général j'aime en une copie
les comédies françaises
weber ou home et grands
camille
leurs capitaux à hollywood avant
ma [__] manier voulu qu on va payer je
le dis ici aucune
envie qu'est ce qui vous a énervé
récemment chez tom cruise
je connais iphone fait
c'est sa religion scientologues c'est
tout match at home a été un petit peu
étroit d'esprit c'est quelqu'un de très
sympa que je connais très bien on a vécu
quand même il meurt pendant longtemps en
douceur et sami mois mais cette année je
crois qu'il a pris peur fermé mais il va
se rouvrir je pense dans les années à
venir c'est c'est ce que je pense sinon
vous couvrir de films de
soumah production m'enfin c'est un très
bon oeil à gaspard qui arrivent mais
qu'est ce que n'importe quelle actrice a
de plus que nicole kidman
moi j'ai fait sept films avec nicole
kidman y compris le film pour lequel
elle égrène oscars c'est une idée
absolument ce trader extraordinaire sur
tous ses aspects et films comiques
sérieux nicole kidman
et tout un cieux
accepté à 15 millions $ d'un studio est
bien normal travaillent gratuitement sur
ds ce que j'ai fait avec elle ou encore
une fois
sur un petit projet elle est très
généreuse qu'elle filme avez vous
regretté de produire
être
prêt à porter avec robert altman mon
problème c'est que j'ai jamais rencontré
marché de masse très
ami avec sophia loren ya un film et j'ai
oublié de faire mon job de producteurs
j'ai passé mon temps avec marcello
toute la journée jeux la compagnie du
matin au soir il m'a emmené à déjeuner
il me racontait toutes les anecdotes sur
fellini des sica
tous les ses héros de mon enfance et
leur pendant huit semaines j'ai oublié
mon travail alors robert altman m'a dit
mais je te vois jamais tu passes tout
autant avec marcello
alors l'objet n'ai pas pu vraiment
participer au film
[Musique]
mais
tant que pas aller
[Musique]
j'ai accueilli bernard brochand
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
chambon soir mais toi à vous n'avez pas
fixé avant votre vie mais vous êtes
aujourd'hui le maire de cannes quel
bilan tirez vous du dernier festival je
crois que ça et d'ailleurs on l'a dit
tout à l'heure là c'est un très bon
festival d'abord très bon festival par
par les films on a rarement une
sélection aussi bonne par le jury qui a
été élu aussi exceptionnels et hors
marché s'il faut jamais oublier que
derrière le festival il ya un marché et
les manettes et des noyaux ça c'était
avant ça c'était avant c'est fini les
manettes c'est fini je crois que c'est
fait vous n'avez pas tué je crois que
ces vidéos et des sacs en papier quoique
c'est fini et donc il ya un marché c'est
la première fois qu'on dépasse dans le
marché 10000 participants au marché
était tout à fait bon il ya eu des
vendeurs et des acheteurs et donc c'est
un très bon festival bien il n'y a
qu'une chose je vous êtes dresse une
supplique bernard est ce que vous
pourriez faire détruire le palais du
festival le bunker et en faire un autre
parce que franchement c'est une laideur
c'est inimaginable
oui oui la salle de cinéma et pas très
bien en plus à leurs excuses et le
détruire bernard écouter on est de
détruire nous sommes complètement
d'accord pour le reconstruire mais si
vous voulez créer un vrai architecte un
vrai architectes ne dit pas celui qui
était là n'est pas un cédez pas à mon
sens il est déprimé quand il a fait ça
c'était très sale et primes tout le
monde il ne fait vrai c'est le viol et
les faunes référence très sérieusement
si vous voulez là c'est un groupe c'est
un gros sapin demande quand même parce
que détruire le bunker faut-il pendant
ce temps là que le festival continue par
exemple
on peut à des faits mais ils foutent
rien notre truc à trop de vieux canet
sainte croix aux six agrès problème cela
on va régler ça
à le reconstruire va oui oui sauf qu'il
faut trouver un système de transition on
va pas s'ils voulaient leur presque on
peut reconstruire au même endroit
comment parce que le festival on peut
pas l'arrêter il n'y a pas que le
festival vous savez galmi pim la midem
assad
comme le 300 gagnent haut il ya plein de
froid congrès qu'un mec taxons vivre la
ville et du spectacle aussi alors que
cannes pour vous c'est un peu le retour
de l'enfant prodigue ce que vous êtes né
à cannes votre grand père était le
patron du grand magasin les dames de
france votre père était expert comptable
votre père et a disparu très tôt en 1959
voilà et alors votre vie est racontée
dans un livre de pierre dominique
cochard qui s'appelle vous pouvez
réussir l'impossible position naturelle
contre le pessimisme chez timée éditions
alors on apprend vous n'êtes pas passés
loin d'une carrière de footballeur
professionnel
vous avez gagné la coupe gambardella
avec la et scan en cadets surclassés oui
absolument j'aurais pu être un très bon
joueur professionnel je les ai fait
pratiquement tout en continuant mes
études mais c'est vrai que le football
ne m'a jamais quitté c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui encore j'attends avec
impatience la sélection
la sélection absolument schéma qu'elle
passait parce que
je vienne pour couper ou pour barthez
vous eh bien je moi j'aurais dit coupez
j'aurais pris le risque ouais alors on
63 effectivement après vos études à hec
ou fait le service militaire dans la
royale dans la marine et vous êtes en
quarts de finale de la coupe de france
avec l'asbh brestois rit oui et c'était
la grande équipe du racing qu'on a battu
si vous voulez 1-0 en finale alors en 69
vous avez 30 ans vous travaillé pour la
société procter and gamble et vous
entrez en contact avec l' agence de
publicité ddb la fameuse agence de bill
burns bac qui est une star mondiale
évidemment qui a fait cette campagne
extraordinaire pour volkswagen tout à
fait avec marc et il se glisse petit
gadget frère dont il montre et le fameux
lem qui montraient qu'ils ont été ou qui
monte au ciel et il avait mis il se
glisse bâti get you there signé
volkswagen c'est à dire il comparait le
lem qui était extrêmement laid et qui
montaient donc c'est un show créatif
c'est pas vous sortir et que vous dire
ça vous connaissent et savent mieux que
quiconque vous avez dirigé ddb en france
pendant des années donc grandes agences
c'est là qu'on s'est connus absolument
plus de trente ans qu il ya eu la
fameuse campagne canada dry qui doit
encore dans les esprits aujourd'hui fait
la couleur de nalco le goût de l'alcool
mais ce n'est pas l'alcool quoi alors on
parler de cinéma avec harry weinstein et
à régler la main vous travaillez à
l'époque avec jean jacques annaud jean
jacques annaud molinaro surtout des tous
des jeunes metteurs en scène acquis à
l'époque nous avons fait confiance et
c'est vrai que ça a été pour nous un là
aussi une nouvelle vague puisque vous
avez fait partie cette nouvelle vague
après 68 ya eu dans la publicité
française en tout cas un renouveau
complet là aussi toute une génération
nouvelle apprise et rigolo prix pouvoir
c'est très rigolo ensuite vous entrez
dans le groupe havas ou diriger le la
publicité chez havas donc euros comme
vous faites la fameuse campagne darty le
contrat de conférences quoi alors
ensuite il ya des problèmes vous créer
une agence qui s'appelle femmes ou les
femmes devaient faire la publicité pour
les femmes oui j'avais des idées je
croyais que la femme très bien marché a
très bien marché c'est en creux comme
junior oui c'étaient là des enfants qui
faisait de la publicité ça n'a pas très
bien marché et puis vous vous heurtez au
caractère particulier davasse parce qu'à
val c'était l'actionnariat public donc
une espèce de courroie de transmission
de l'elysée de matignon c'est l'époque
où mitterrand vient d'être élu et à
l'époque vous songé à partir quand andré
rousselet vous convaincre de travailler
sur le projet de ce qu'on appelait
encore à l'époque la quatrième chaîne
c'est-à-dire canal et vous participez à
la fondation de canal+ tout à fait qui a
été une aventure absolument
extraordinaire et là aussi on voit bien
que quand on crée une nouvelle chaîne
c'est quelque chose qui nécessite comme
toujours malgré tout des talents et
l'invention
qu'apporter pierre lescure c'est vous
qui avez une idée de lescure oui c'est
moi qui suis allé le chercher parce qu'à
un moment donné justement ce qui avait
fait charger de cette chaîne n'était pas
justement suffisamment talentueux pour
faire de l'innovation de la nouveauté et
surtout sa première chaîne payante là
aussi il fallait savoir quel concept on
allait mettre en avant le concept en
avant bienvenue c'était le sport
particulièrement le football et et le
cinéma et sur ces deux concepts après il
y avait la multidiffusion il y avait
toute une série de choses qui permettait
justement là aussi d'être de changer
complètement la nature je crois des
télévisions de l'effet alors en 88 vous
prenez part à la campagne
présidentielle de chirac mais c'est
malheureusement mitterrand qui gagnent
vous quittez havas vous retournez chez
gd des bêcher dolganes deux bagues et là
vous devenez président de l' agence
monde tout à fait c'est quand même
énorme c'est à dire que là moi je suis
ce qui m'étonne le plus dans votre
carrière c'est le français qui devient
patron mondial d'une agence américaine
ils sont venus véritablement on me
demandait et je suis devenu donc
président ronde de
1989 à
2003 et donc pendant douze ans j'ai
dirigé 15000 personnes 15 milliards de
chiffre d'affaires sans caracas est
énorme c'était énorme mais surtout ce
qui était intéressant c'était que s'ils
voulaient là aussi c'était la
mondialisation un français si vous
voulez qui quand même à les vendre
l'amérique en chine 3 il fallait le
budweiser par exemple que nous avons
lancée en chine où bien d'autres temps
d'autres pays vous pouvez réussir
l'impossible salah et vous êtes client
alors au début quand vous arrivez dans
cette agence il ya 44 pays dans le monde
et à la fin il ya 145 pays donc vous
avez gagné 101 pays vous avez implanté
l'agencé inclure aussi ça veut dire
aussi beaucoup de travail ça veut dire
pendant 12 ans en 80 jours par an dans
les avions ça veut dire aussi un
changement de ma vie personnelle et qui
comme toujours le principal acte que je
pouvais faire c'était recruté comme
toujours ce n'est pas contrairement à se
produire s'est inventé c'est recruter
partout où j'allais les meilleurs en
particulier les meilleurs créatifs c'est
donc une vaste recherche s'ils voulaient
d'hommes capable d'adhérer à une
certaine philosophie publicitaire une
certaine culture d'entreprise et est
véritablement il fallait que j'y aille
pour les convaincre de venir avec nous
plutôt que d'aller avec d'autres alors
vous êtes président du psg à ce
moment-là vous cherchez quelqu'un pour
reprendre effectivement le psg alors au
départ berlusconi est sur le coup tout
le monde a peur que ça soit berlusconi
tf1 refuse la clt rtl refuse lagardère
échaudés par la sphère matra racing
n'est pas trop envieux de s'occuper et
vous le vendez à canal finalement c'est
vous qui avez organisé chez moi qui
organisais le tour de table du caj de
canal et c'est vrai que ça a été une
aventure formidable et là aussi si vous
voulez comme toujours quel est
l'objectif que vous suivez quel est le
style de joueur tout joueur qu'il
fallait choisir quel était ce qui
attendait pari pari manqué de ce
football professionnel et là aussi il a
fallu créer une stratégie à y réfléchir
avant et on a un est allé chercher des
brésiliens et ce n'était pas pour rien
si on a choisi les entraîneurs
particulier puisque part il faut à la
fois des résultats il faut à la fois un
football chatoyant et c'est pour ça
qu'on a pu faire venir de ricardo valdo
aille à leonardo un type comme leonardo
qui était parti à milan m'a téléphoné
pour me dire président
surtout n'allez pas au stade de france
on est chez nous au parc des princes
quand même extraordinaire pour la part
d'un joueur brésilien en
1998 vous venez passer des vacances
afghane et c'est là que vous décidez de
vous présenter à la mairie votre grand
père vous avez dit tu as été favorisée
par la vie un jour il faudra que tu
rendent et vous décidé de rendre aux
gens aux citoyens que vous savez j'avais
aussi un temps 60 ans je crois que
j'avais fait le tour de la publicité on
m'a proposé à ce moment-là de devenir
patron de la holding américain omnicom
qui a un premier groupe publicitaire
mondial il fallait vraiment que j'allais
vivre à new york complètement c'était
plus un job là financier qu'un job je
voulais quitter un job là aussi proche
du terrain proche des campagnes est donc
là aussi ça faisait des années que je
voyais cette ville comme vous avez
décrite où il se passait des choses
quand même qu'ils n'étaient pas tout à
fait normal c'est terrible c'était le
clientélisme la corruption et c'était
incroyable comme vous dites et et c'est
vrai que cette ville était mal barré il
fallait là il fallait la reprendre et je
pense que j'ai bien fait je suis très
content d'être maire de la ville de
cannes il se passe des choses à cannes
mais là aussi vous savez cannes est une
ville est là aussi très locale très
provincial avec des pêcheurs avec des
habitants mais aussi de vie très
international moi ce qui me frappe tous
les jours au niveau des congrès c'est
que je retrouve mes clients ce que j'ai
rencontré partout dans le monde entier
et est géré et très curieusement quand
j'ai dit à ddb que je partais et qu' il
avait très peur que je parte à la
conclura en soit hier quand je leur ai
dit que j'essayais j'allais essayer de
devenir maire de cannes et bien écoutez
ils ont été très fiers et et
le board à l'époque m'a applaudi voyez
comme quoi américains là aussi on
certain respect de ce qu'ils y font
pareil le public est infatigable parce
que non seulement vous êtes maire de
cannes et vous êtes parti dans une
nouvelle mission c'est la chaîne d'info
internationale française le cnn à la
française
je crois que je suis tout à fait
essentiel pour notre pays qu'on est une
chaîne internationale concurrents de cnn
bbc world al jazira car notre présence
mondiale et notre présence sur le
terrain nécessite en effet que l'on
puisse parler de la france mais parler
de l'économie parler de ceux qui font ce
pays et qui veulent conquérir le monde
en ce sens c'est vrai quand on a vu
comment les américains ont traité les
émeutes en banlieue voilà la fin 2005 on
aimerait qu'il est une chaîne française
pour expliquer les prises de position de
notre gouvernement par rapport à la
guerre en irak les discours qui ont été
faits à l'onu jamais ils ont été
retransmis sur une chaîne internationale
c'est là on a bien vu si vous voulez la
nécessité d'avoir un moyen d'information
vous avez d'appeler france 1 j'espère
n'ont peut-être moi j'aime bien fait non
ça me semblerait normal car il y aura le
mot pour moi je dois être à l'intérieur
oui en tous les cas vous avez une devise
qui est assez drôle celle inverse de
coubertin c'est l'essentiel n'est pas de
participer mais de gagner oui je crois
si vous voulez aujourd'hui à force de
participer ont participé ont fait rien
et je crois gagner c'est faire quelque
chose et puis quand on perd on perd je
veux dire par là il faut pas désespérer
vous savez comme toujours au football
c'est le prochain match est important
hélas hélas il très important de
redonner cette volonté de gagner ça
c'est quand on est perdant cantonné
poulidor quand on perd les jeux
olympiques quand ton père qui avait tout
ce que l'on perd à un moment donné eh
bien on fait plus rien quand on est
désespéré et ça c'est ça aussi un
élément important pour la confiance en
soi mais quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur votre ami chirac bah
écoutez moi j'ai des relations j'ai
toujours eu des relations sous les
excellentes années q je crois que
aujourd'hui ce monsieur le président que
je respecte ne se représentera pas et
dans l'instant où il se représente pas
et bien il faut penser à ce qui va se
passer après je crois qu'aujourd'hui
nous devons penser c'est à dire la
france d'après parce que ça va parler de
slogans qui existe mais est évident que
aujourd'hui la france pendant cette
année je dirais 2006 et tout le monde de
gauche de droite les grands les petits
les vieux les jeunes doivent se
préoccuper de ce que va devenir ce pays
car aujourd'hui on ne peut pas rester
dans l'état où on est on peut pas rester
dans l'état économique dans l'état
social est véritablement nous comptons
et personnellement en tout cas je compte
beaucoup que l'on puisse en effet
retrouvé réformer ce pays pour que là
encore on retrouve quand même une france
dynamique confiante et pas pessimiste et
pas déprimé comme elle l'est aujourd'hui
à toul à tout moment je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a perdu 7 parler de
mon grand père mon père quand j'étais
avec lui à cannes il ya 50 ans
maintenant c'était un monsieur qui
chantait tout le temps qu'ils étaient
heureux qui qui joue aux boules qui
faisait il y avait une joie de vivre
mieux oui un fainéant un feignant il
travaille aussi beaucoup mais mais mais
je crois que c'est ça qui nous manque et
je pense que d'ailleurs on le voit dans
votre émission et je le dis je voyais
vous essayez quand même malgré tout tous
les événements que vous abordez en
donnant cette chaux côté positif
je suis pas retourné le couteau dans la
plaie parce que ça s'arrête la nation
mais justement ça va s'arrêter
renault vous êtes responsable des médias
l'express vous pensez quoi bernard
brochand
ses personnages qu'elle comptait qui a
pesé dans le paysage publicitaire est un
grand monsieur respectée qu'à une
magnifique carrière c'est vrai merci
très diverses en plus on a eu très chaud
en hiver
une belle destinée en tout cas je trouve
ouais tiens dominique lechat vous pouvez
réussir l'impossible selon bernard
brochand c
et chez timée éditions mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
non merci d'avoir le cas avec nous
la nuit là
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir grand reporter mobile est
aujourd'hui entre paris et moscou vous
collaborer régulièrement l hebdomadaire
le point auparavant pour le compte de
ouest-france et de libération vous avez
couvert le conflit tchétchène et vous
avez obtenu en l'an 2000 le prix albert
londres pour chienne de guerre chez
fayard vous publié aujourd'hui toujours
chez fayard par les monts et les plaines
d'asie centrale donc j'étais allé
visiter toutes les républiques
ex soviétiques qui se termine par ce
temps et qui suscite l'intérêt des
grandes puissances mondiales oui on du
pétrole oui oui les républiques
issermann par
les connaissez
l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan les
capitales en
plus de nos selon les régimes on sait
très loin mais cc frontalier de la chine
au nord de l'afghanistan au sud de la
russie en gros un espace grand comme
l'europe occidentale tout entière c'est
bien desservi au niveau des bus les bus
ou un internat d'accord les avions c'est
un peu plus compliqué c'est toute
l'ancienne compagnie aeroflot en face et
tout l'espace ex-soviétique donc on
connaît pas du tout et surtout on a
l'impression qu'ils s'y passe rien c'est
pour ça que évidemment dans les médias
et à rien mais moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse et n attend pas qui s'y
passe quelque chose pour y aller j'y
vais je parle avec les gens j'écoute ce
qu'ils me disent et je retransmets
j'essaye tout simplement de de
rapprocher ce jour là sur lesquelles on
connaît rien de nous alors si république
en fait suscite l'intérêt de toutes les
grandes puissances mondiales parce que
les chinois on voit des commerçants les
réussissent aimerait bien les garder les
américains y installe des bases face
c'est quand même un lieu effectivement
ça bouge beaucoup quoi oui ça bouge
beaucoup il ya deux dates importantes
c'est d'abord la fin de l'urss en 1991
donc la série publiques dans lesquelles
personne n'allait on commence à pouvoir
y aller qui va en premier évidemment les
américains parce que il ya des
hydrocarbures il ya du gaz il ya du
pétrole y en a vraiment beaucoup donc
les multinationales pétrolières
américaines ils vont s'installe nous les
français on met beaucoup plus de temps à
s'installer deuxième date 11 septembre
2001 au lendemain du 11 septembre une
fois de plus les américains se disent il
faut quand même un endroit un peu de
retrait par rapport aux opérations qu'on
est en train de faire en afghanistan
donc il demande à ces pays s'ils peuvent
installer des bases militaires ils ont
réussi à s'installer dans deux pays au
kirghizstan et en ouzbékistan au
kirghizstan qui est quand même le seul
pays au monde dans lequel il ya deux
base distante de quelques kilomètres à
peine l'une américaine l'autre ex
soviétique arrivé à chorus mais les
rigides eux voient ça d'un très mauvais
oeil je veux bien sûr parce que pour les
russes c'est encore ce qu'ils appellent
d'ailleurs très poétiquement l'étranger
proche c'est-à-dire presque pas
l'étranger c'est-à-dire russe
aujourd'hui ils sont très vexé de devoir
acheter un visa pour pouvoir aller au
kazakhstan parce que avant c'était
empire soviétique pointures dont qu'ils
essayent de récupérer en tout cas de ne
pas perdre leur influence sur place
c'est comme s'il ya des bases russes au
lexique quoi voilà
exactement alors vous avez une technique
vous fondez comme ça dans dans la masse
comme une espèce de caméléon vous
habillé en femme local voyager en taxis
collectifs
c'est très efficace et plus sûre sur
monde une méthode tout simplement enfin
on appelle ça maintenant il m'étonne moi
c'est ma façon de travailler normal j'ai
commencé par le pire la guerre en
tchétchénie je crois qu'il ya pas pire
comme école dans le journalisme et dans
la correspondance de guerre
l'idée de me faire remarquer en
tchétchénie évidemment c'était c'était
ce n'était pas le bienvenu donc c'était
clair quand tu utilises les m'habiller
comme une femme tchétchène donc je le
fais naturellement en irak je suis
irakienne on avait en afghanistan je
suis je parle beaucoup de langues dans
chaque pays essaye je suis en train
d'apprendre l'arabe je parle sept
langues couramment dont le russe puisque
j'habite en russie depuis dix ans n'en
perd soviétique était grand on peut
encore parler russe dans toutes ses
dents toutes ces républiques mais ça
aide de parler la langue parce que si
j'arrive avec un intermédiaire si
j'arrive avec un quelqu'un qui va
traduire qui n'est pas de la famille les
gens vont se méfier ils vont évidemment
jamais me parler me dire les choses qui
me dirait si je suis le seul en face à
face avec eux ouais donc l'important
c'est de gagner leur confiance et en
même temps c'est efficace et sûr parce
que en étant habillés comme eu en
parlant comme eux ils vous racontent des
choses qui raconterait pas évidemment un
journaliste qui s'afficherait comme tel
et puis c'est moins dangereux que si
vous arriviez en jean et un et anti char
du mans première raison c'est la
sécurité ma propre sécurité il est clair
que si j'arrive à billets comme si je
suis ce soir à bagdad je me fait
immédiatement remarquer impossible et
potentiellement à qui a kidnappé alors
que moi j'essaye de faire le contraire
c'est d'ailleurs d'être la plus discrète
possible de me fondre dans la population
un con et un billet comme ça est
également en prenant les bus justement
les moyens de transports locaux les bus
ça marche toujours même dans les pays en
guerre les minibus les navettes les
taxis en commun puisque les taxis cc
trochain donc il est souvent plus tôt 4
5 personnes dans un taxi et puis je me
tate confié dans un taxi j'ai pas besoin
de parler pour qu'on pourra fille chez
qui je suis j'ai besoin simplement de
passer d'un courageux quand même mais
vous avez quoi comme papier sur vous si
jamais vous fait j'y mets ma pied
français et français mais j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours l'espoir que je vais pas
me faire contrôler ça m'est arrivé une
fois en tchétchénie la fois où un soldat
russe m'a finalement demandé mes papiers
alors que j'étais habillé en femme
tchétchène et que j'étais assise
derrière et non pas devant parce que
c'est comme ça on s'est serré les femmes
106 derrière et que normalement on
adresse pas vraiment la parole à une
femme il n'aurait pas dû me demander mes
papiers mais a demandé là j'ai hésité je
les lui ai donné mes papiers cv papier
français bien sûr et je me suis dit bon
évidemment il va appeler au taquet
walkie et c'est terminé je me faire
arrêter et le mec qu'il avait 18 19 ans
il était je crois un peu paniqué de voir
un passeport étranger et puis il a rien
fait on est reparti et ombres avec mon
chauffeur qui était un copain on a
évident évidemment éviter le post
suivant pour passer autrement mais il
faut prendre le risque j'avais peur
c'est pas le moment où j'ai plus peur le
moment où j'ai plus peur c'est
évidemment sous les bombardements et
quand j'ai vu des gens ouvrir évidemment
sous ces bombardements parce qu'à la
guerre aux moeurs il faut le rappeler
aujourd'hui en irak sarij publié
également chez fayard islamistes comment
ils nous voient alors qui est un compte
rendu de voyage au pakistan en
afghanistan en irak alors vous avez
interrogé des religieux des des talibans
d où les mavs interrogé des combattants
des moudjahidine des intellectuels des
politiques des professeurs de simples
croyants c'est à dire moi ce qui m'a
intéressé dans ce petit livre islamistes
comment ils nous voient c'est vraiment
de faire l'inversé de ce qu'ont de ce
qu'on a produit surtout depuis le 11
septembre 2001 il ya des myriades de
livres sur l'islam sur comment nous les
voyons plutôt comment nous ne les voyons
pas parce que nous les comprenons pas et
j'ai simplement voulu faire l' inverse
inverser le regarde c'est à dire essayer
de leur demander comment eux ils nous
voient comment ils se voient eux mêmes
comment ils voient leur propre vie ou
leur survie dans la guerre et je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils avaient bien sûr
autant d'idées reçues et de stéréotypes
surnom que nous avons sur eux lorsque
nous le gros amalgame
amalgame le plus fréquent ces musulmans
égale terroristes en gros en très gros
oeufs c'est occident sans faire la
différence entre les pays français
américains italiens c'est occident égale
ennemis de l'islam
donc on est mal parti pour s'entendre
quand on quand on quand on quand on a ça
au départ mais quand on va sur place
comme ce que je fais comme les gens
lisent le terrain font mais on se rend
compte que il faut forcément entend ce
qu'ils nous disent même si c'est pas
agréable à entendre bien sûr que c'est
pas agréable en temps et bien sûr que la
plupart de mes interlocuteurs ont tenu
des propos violemment anti occidentaux
et j'avais envie de les couper toutes
les secondes et d'en dire j'étais pas
d'accord et moi mon but c'est qu'ils
m'ont dit encore plus c'est que vraiment
ils parlent pour qu'on puisse se rend
compte de ce qu'il pense éventuellement
réagir alors on va prendre les
malentendus donc il ya d'abord un
malentendu géopolitique c'est dire leur
rejet de l'impérialisme et de
l'occupation américaine sûr que ça oui
ça paraît évident sur place il est assez
difficile d'être d'accord avec celui qui
vous occupe militairement que ce soit en
irak qu'en afghanistan aujourd'hui il ya
une armée étrangère qui occupent le pays
sans rien dire que les habitants
n'arrivent pas à vivre normalement tout
est compliqué d'aller d'un point a à un
point b de savoir ce qu'on va faire
demain c'est vraiment très compliqué il
ya quelques jours il ya quand même une
femme enceinte qui s'est fait tué lors
d'un checkpoint justement routier à
bagdad tout simplement parce que c'était
pas arrêté là où il fallait exactement
s'arrêter puis là il ya eu a du talent
oui il ya ce massacre de haditha qui
date de novembre 2005 sur 128 les
pinceaux comme à l'époque de millage et
tout ça quoi c'est tout à fait c'est
tout à fait comparable mais là aussi
c'est intéressant de voir que notre
vision différente de la leur parce que
pour nous c'est une découverte c'est en
train de faire un scandale ici aux
etats-unis mais pas pour eux pour eux
c'est pas une découverte pour eux ils le
savaient que ce massacre avait eu lieu
tout le monde le savait et pour eux
c'est tous les jours la même chose c'est
tous les jours la guerre le massacre
donc si vous voulez ce qu'on leur donne
de la démocratie ce que nous on voudrait
qu'ils acceptent comme la démocratie est
qu'ils acceptent en applaudissant et
bien pour eux c'est très négatif
c'est-à-dire quand on demande
aujourd'hui un afghan base ou un irakien
de base qu'est ce que c'est la
démocratie va vous dire la démocratie
c'est le kidnapping quotidien le chaos
la corruption l'insécurité
donc que des choses négatives mais il
sait pas ce que c'est la démocratie
comme chez nous donc évidemment il peut
pas vraiment en avoir envie alors 2e
malentendu le malentendu idéologique
alors il nous reproche finalement notre
individualisme et le libéralisme voir le
libertarisme de nos comportements quoi
oui il effectivement là on a affaire des
sociétés c'est pour ça que j'essaie de
m'adapter le plus possible comme comme
comme un peu un caméléon tout simplement
de a à e parce que ces sociétés sont
très différentes des nôtres moi puisque
je suis une femme j'ai le droit quand je
suis en irak ou en afghanistan d'être
avec les femmes alors qu'un reporter
hommes ne pourraient pas le faire ce que
je fais c'est à dire ils n'auraient
accès qu'aux hommes moi j'ai bien sûr
accès aux hommes en premier parce que ce
sont les hommes qui font la guerre parce
que ce sont les hommes qui sont dans la
rue ce sont les hommes qui palabrent etc
mais ensuite quand je rentre dans les
familles parce que j'habite chez les
gens je suis pas à l'hôtel évidemment
j'ai séché les gens ça c'est important
les femmes attendent avec impatience
après le dîner de me voir et de me
parler et donc j'ai leur version des
choses qui évidemment différente de
celle des hommes et qui la complète et
ça c'est très important c'est à dire que
ils ont d une vision encore des rapports
hommes femmes qui sont pas du tout les
nôtres je me rappelle de cette femme
irakienne ni drette à kirkouk au nord de
bagdad qui me professeur d'anglais donc
est quand même assez ouverte
intelligente qui me disait quand je l'aï
revue là au mois de novembre à quel
point elle était choquée de savoir qu'en
occident ça va faire rire tout le monde
mais qu'en occident un homme et une
femme qui sont rencontre qu'ils se
connaissent pas pauvre immédiatement
avant des relations sexuelles et elle me
disait qu est ce qu on fait des enfants
mais avec la plus grande naïveté sans
même se rendre compte que effectivement
la contraception existe c'est à dire
c'est inconcevable pour elle donc là on
est vraiment loin de la façon dont on
vit chez nous habiller le malentendu
médiatique donc la désinformation les
amalgames c'est à dire bon tous les
terroristes sont des musulmans et tous
les musulmans sont des terroristes ou
les occidentaux sont des ans soeur et
ses espèces de oui la force de la télé
ça c'est très important parce que malgré
toutes les différences que je viens
d'énoncer on a tous quelque chose en
commun nous ici les terroristes les
fondamentalistes ou les simples
musulmans c'est qu'on regarde la télé
tout le monde regarde la télé même là
bas même en afghanistan où il n'y a pas
d'électricité dans des villages où les
brouilles pour brancher sur une batterie
tracteur tout le village se retrouve
autour de de ce petit écran bleuté et
qu'est ce qu'ils voient même s'il
comprend pas ce qui est dit il est
choqué par les images ivoire d d d
horreur des choses qui font peur qui
peuvent attirer et faire peur en même
temps ma seule présence parfois dans ces
familles je l' ai sentis auprès
de ces femmes qui me posaient des
questions autant de questions finalement
que moi je leur posais parce qu'elles
sont curieuses parce qu'elle voir si
elles veulent justement vérifier si ce
qu'elle voit à la télé c'est c'est vrai
prouvé qu'elle pouvait avoir des
réactions très différentes soit une
envie c'est à dire mon indépendance de
femmes occidentales ma liberté leur
faisait envie leur ouvrait des horizons
nouveaux ou alors les terrifier tout
simplement parce que c'est tellement
différent que c'est pas possible alors
c'est vrai que l' affaire des
caricatures de mahomet a montré que le
fossé se creuse que chacun vit avec ses
stéréotypes ces idées fausses sa
propagande et peut-être que cette
histoire de choc des civilisations
vraiment arrivé moi je prend
malheureusement qu on est en plein
dedans le choc des civilisations c'est
ce fameux livre de samuel huntington
gros personne n'a vraiment lui en tout
cas mes interlocuteurs sur place qu'ils
soient très intellectuel ou pas du tout
que ce soit des mérites de base ils en
ont tous parlé c'est donc que c'est
vraiment une idée qui les a marqués ils
ont l'impression d'être dans le choc des
civilisations c'est à dire qu'on ne peut
déjà plus se parler c'est déjà trop tard
moi j'aimerais se livre un peu une
sonnette d'alarmé j'aimerais croire
qu'on est con n'est pas encore dedans
mais quand je rentre parce que je crois
que pour les reporters de guerre le plus
important c'est le plus dur c'est pas de
partir partiront part parce qu'on aime
ça parce qu'on aime aller dans ces pays
mais c'est revenir revenir ici et s'être
face à l'indifférence cette espèce de
bulle de confort dans lequel on se
complaît tous ici et qui fait qu'on a
l'impression que personne ne vit
autrement que nous un peu c'est très
difficile à l'extérieur donc justement
le petit effort d'inverser le regard est
même difficile on a des raisons d'être
inquiet alors
je crois oui on a des raisons d'être
inquiet parce que le monde va très mal
surtout quand on sort de cette bulle
enfin déjà ici chez nous ça va pas très
bien mais ça j'ai pas écrit deux livres
donc je connais pas très bien beau la
france 2 connaît mieux l'afghanistan
l'irak ailleurs ça va très mal le
terrorisme c'est un drame et
malheureusement
si on continue disons à ne pas dialoguer
a montré une espèce d'arrogance ou ce
que perçoit comme une arrogance ça va
être encore pire il ya un truc qui
trouve grâce à leurs yeux c'est la
technologie un les portables ouais c'est
la seule chose de l'occident enfin quand
on y vote libre c'est la seule chose de
l'occident qu'ils acceptent quoi ouais
ouais ils ont ce rapport très attendu à
l'occident tout ce qui tout ce qu'ils
aiment pas dans l'occident vient on
vient d'en parler
mais en même temps ils peuvent pas ne
pas être attiré par certaines choses et
certaines choses c'est bien sûr la
modernité la technologie nous selon les
téléphones portables c'est vrai que
j'avais des interlocuteurs hallucinant
directeur de mai dressa d'écoles
coraniques à peshawar qui sortait un
téléphone portable de leurs de leur
poche ensuite un deuxième puis un
troisième avec des sonneries
hallucinante il s'échange tout ça sur
les fichiers mp3 et on est assis en
tailleur sur c'est incroyable ça c'est
la cohabitation des deux raies modernité
et puis ce côté qu'on pourrait juger un
peu rétrograde en tous les cas dans la
vie quotidienne voilà mais il faut qu'on
le sache non occidentaux saisir ils sont
pas que rétrograde ils ont ils acceptent
aussi des choses c'est nous donc ça
donne un mélange assez difficile à
comprendre et que ça pourrait pas
s'arranger avec une soirée portal on
pourra passer
allez
chez fayard
monsieur
comment il voit
c'est aussi chez fayard la laddh
messieurs
jacques alors engelberger
[Musique]
avant toute chose yelle
voilà qu'elle se couvre maintenant non
mais ce qui surtout on doit libérer la
nounou libérer la nounou libéré
m
messi
sa femme
tu en es content ce qu'il faut qu'elle
soit contente de moi ça de bas salaires
oui oui ça se passe bien si vous vivez
bien l'échangé ce site alors lorraine
vous est né en pennsylvanie en 1977 vous
vivez à new york depuis
1999 et après vos études universitaires
voulait devenir journaliste et vous vous
retrouvez assistante de la rédactrice en
chef du magazine vogue et un jour dans
un atelier d'écriture on vous demande
d'écrire une quinzaine de pages vous
raconter votre expérience chez bob donc
et ce texte deviendra un best seller
mondial sous le titre le diable
s'habille en prada qui s'est vendu à des
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde
entier belle histoire
alors merci je ne sais pas quand vous
savez tout ça sur moi je suis
impressionné alors avec tout l'argent
que vous avez gagné vous avez continué à
écrire et aujourd'hui vous publié chez
fleuve noir people or not people qui est
déjà numéro 10 dans la liste du nouvel
obs alors le pitch est l'histoire de
bêtes qui à 26 ans qu'est ce que vous
faites
c'est pas moi je sais pas moi bon tu
peux me dire et j'en ai rien à [__]
mais tu es viré comme tu vois j'en ai
rien à [__] alors le pitch c'est bête
donc il ya 26 ans qui travaille dans une
banque
dont tu es viré aussi de ce qu'est
le pitch donc ces bêtes qui à 26 ans qui
travaille dans une banque à manhattan où
elle s'ennuie elle vit seul avec son
chien depuis que son petit ami l'a
larguée pour un mannequin et là elle
décide de démissionner et au lieu de
sombrer dans la déprime elle est ravie
elle regarde des émissions idiotes à la
télévision elle lit des romans à l'eau
de rose elle se délecte de son
inactivité
jusqu'au jour où son oncle lui trouve un
job dans une agence d'événementiel et
alors là fini les soirées sous la
couette place aux clubs branchés aux vip
et voilà elle se demander c'est tout le
sujet du livre est-ce qu'il faut être
people ou papy paul qui paul or not
people
and j en suis
finalement elle se prend jeu elle entre
dans seulement c'est un monde qui est
très éloigné de sa réalité 2 de ce
qu'elle avait fait avant a travaillé
dans une banque d'un des très
conservateur et finalement on entre dans
un milieu très glamour et en fait il
faut être vu feu voir il faut rencontrer
les gens importants c'est quelque chose
qui est très sain style devient un mode
de vie très extravagant très branché et
branché avec du champagne des soirées
etc et finalement elle entre dans ce
moment là et elle se rend compte que ce
n'est pas véritablement ce que l'on
pense que ce modèle alors j'espère que
je ne vous dévoile pas la femme hergé en
fait elles arrivent à s'en sortir à la
fin mai vous personnellement vous n'êtes
pas très people en fait
non
je crois que
si elles étaient au moins moitié aussi
glamour que celle de mes personnages
bien ce serait plus drôle mais c'est
génial d'être ici c'est génial d'être en
tournée des traits paris c'est
formidable c'est super vous n'êtes pas
très people parce que vous dites
écrire est la meilleure excuse pour
rester chez soi et parler à personne
pendant des jours et des jours
j'aime bien sortir temps à autre
je crois que sortir tous les soirs
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin avec dans ce
milieu de la drogue et cetera je ne sais
pas quelque chose qui me prend
véritablement est ce que je préfère
écrire je ne sais pas mais bon sortir
temps en temps avec des amis ça c'est
sympa halloween c'est la première fois
que vous venez en france
l'occasion de venir ici lorsque j'essaie
étudiante et puis en décembre dernier je
suis venu ici parce que il est en train
de tourner le film le diable s'habille
en prada ah ouais ah oui très bien
c'était formidable il serait absolument
you you you like food in france vous
aimez la nourriture française
bien sûr qu'il
[Rires]
puise in le vêtement la mode les hommes
il ya plein de choses qu'on puisse ne
pas aimer en france vraiment
digéré six mois que ça
est une bond et si soignée
comme il beaucoup plus soignée que les
amériques mais ça qu'ils offrent en
chair à pâté
weinberger plus fort
c'est publié chez fleuve noir mesdames
messieurs
[Musique]
j'accueille jacno
aïe
[Musique]
ce soir
alors la meilleure façon de présenter
jacno c'est ça
[Musique]
morange et qu'on n'a pas
il a payé
et moi que tu m'aimes tous les joueurs
sont les mêmes
tu
[Musique]
mon frère
je
les fermions régime
sa demande m sûrement
la ville demeure seulement le combat
[Musique]
m
suite m
[Musique]
moulay paris - jacques neau
seconde compte
on se rend compte quand on écoute ça
c'est qu'en fait vous êtes plus célèbres
pour votre côté technoïde
initiateur de la french touch que par le
plein de crocs des stinky toys
finalement oui probablement mais bien
sûr c'est à dire que même jean stinky
toys c'était du groupe de rock père
sauvages qui sont un truc qu'on fait à
18 ans mais c'était normal
et puis après évidemment
en ce qui me concerne j'ai fait tout de
suite autre chose que tu es un peu
passer pour des truc de martien allait
peu à ce moment là un trait il y avait
beaucoup d'électronique mais qu'un fond
comme ça un peu
guitaristique
c'est très très en avance finalement
ouais ouais mais c'est plutôt un
inconvénient ça ouais
alors aujourd'hui vous sortez un album
qui s'appelle tant de temps que la
presse spécialisée salue comme du grand
jacques neau rock et folk a dit un album
pop ultime et hors du temps
je suis ravie je suis ravi qui dit ça
parce que c'est un peu le but du jeu
moi je voulais faire un truc comment
dire un peu hors normes et justement
hors du temps c'est à dire hors de la
mode deux sont à la mode du système de
mixage qui est
très
formaté qui actuellement sur le furent
des plus du pure chanson
qu'ils soient un plaisir quoi les
singles c'est ça
mais lente et douloureuse
le sport
forte des parents
[Musique]
voilà jacno le sport jacquiau de 14 juin
la cigale au revoir à quoi ça ressemble
je reviens de votre caméra jacno sais où
j'ai là c'est le cadre ou judith magnéto
serge mcginn et aux chercheurs
bp
un ballon c'est pour les cons
arrêté le sport réduire les maladies
cardiaques
ag
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un sport c'est de la merde
ajaccio
sport
mais ses aventures le corps
et c'est chez warner music
[Musique]
et c'est déjà l'hymne de l'équipe de
france mais j'ose espérer alors vous
dites que le sport c'est de la merde
mais en même temps quand on voit ce
qu'ils prennent dans le cyclisme ça
devrait vous plaît on a mélangé
justement mais moi je suis plutôt contre
la drogue est donc là si on parle de
sport c'est quand même une bande de
drogués de milliardaires en short qui
court intervalle compte c'est très
spécial et tout ça est payé par une
vente principalement de pauvres donc de
jean compact une qui voit les
milliardaires en short complètement
drogué courir après un ballon faire du
vélo enfin la vision mais c'est bien
mais il s'est juste moi c'est juste une
remarque je fais pas de critiques une
constatation qu'on me dise le contraire
tu connais jacques nolwenn
c'est une icône l one way mais ouais
mais j'aime bien alors parallèlement à
cet album vous publié aux éditions du
rocher un livre d'entretiens avec albert
algoud qui s'appelle jacques nos
itinéraires du dandy pop vous raconter
votre vie alors au départ vous êtes une
famille qui est quand même très réac
pas réac vieille france viennent sa
vieille france grand père considérait
que le figaro était un journal de gauche
histoire celle qu avec le fou rire
quelques extraits c'est à dire que
d'elle moi j'étais petit et donc c'était
tout à fait surréaliste et en fait moi
j'ai une vue saab j'ai vu que le côté
poétique de la chose ouais mais t'es
marrant parce qu'ils étaient royalistes
et un jour vous dites pourquoi t'es
royalistes il dit parce que je suis sûr
que rza mes droits oui je trouvais ça
assez beau mais c'est un peu l'histoire
des oui mais toi qui lis avait tout à
fait parce que c'était sûr qu'il aura
jamais trois non bien sûr c'est plus
possible
voilà arrivé aussi votre oncle dd oui
mais c'est dangereux andré zeller
dans des putschistes oui un des
putschistes mais moi je n'ai pas connu
puisqu'il était en prison péri moi je
connaissais sa soeur tante mimi ah voilà
ce qu'il m'a donné que les noms de
dallas
dd c'est andré zeller qui était en
prison avec salants jouhaud et charles
c'était les quatre putschistes d'alger
les généraux factieux comme disait de
gaulle well well ronde quarteron de
généraux fax le bravo laurent ah ouais
c'est pourquoi ils veulent sur le
service public laurent il bossait voilà
ensuite fait tomber dans une pension
catholique chez les frères maristes et
là vous prenez option musique quand même
hein heureusement mais un bon il y avait
des trucs imposé alors je fais de la
flûte à bec puis après flûte traversière
ça pour conclusion que c'est quand même
le seul instrument que je ne supporte
pas c'est plus mon cadeau
heureusement qu' il y avait la
possibilité de guitare mais c'était plus
cher 1 donc ça n'a pas été possible donc
heureusement hein sinon j'aurais jamais
rien fait parce que cette bande de cons
enfin bon c'est quand même
je passe sur les détails
pédophiles de ce type d'endroit que vous
avez tendance à vous comme tout le monde
c'est jean pierre mocky qui racontait
très bien
comment ça se pratique c'est un peu je
te caresse lait emb après puis tu
t'assieds sur moi puis bon évidemment
alors il ya le coup de gueule et moi sur
ce que j'avais fait donc
à ce moment-là tecau les deux week-ends
ouais mais c'est un bon deal il ya
christophe girard qui est venu ici
qu'ils aient cuisse à lui était arrivé
il s'était assis l'avait sur le curé il
avait senti un truc un peu dur et qui
trouvait ça très bien lui comprenait pas
pourquoi le curé était palais n'était
pas allé plus loin ah ben on peut en
être friand voilà qu'un son truc c'est
assez drôle quand j'entends ça
sympathisants ouais si souhaité vous
rencontrer vous raconter votre vie donc
la rencontre avec warhol qui veut vous
sautez lui aussi oui oui bien sûr il
avait un badge avec votre effigie que
t'as qu'à 10 lui avait donné où étiez
vous étiez quand même extrêmement
séduisant mais je me souviens à l'époque
non mais toujours il ya une trentaine
d'années c'est vrai que jacques neuf
chez magnifique dit hier très très beau
garçon je comprends que warhol et envie
de vous sautez ouais ils ont voulu à mon
cul c'est clair mais encore une chanson
les bons et ça s'est pas fait à vous
raconter votre rencontre avec elie alors
elli et jacno ont donc elie faisait
partie du service d'ordre trotskiste
oui comme celui connu et c'était de la
lcr mais les husky ce régime enfin elle
même je pense comme elle avait 16 ans
enfin de toute façon n'était pas au
courant de ce que sérieux en plus elle
arrivé d'uruguay donc oui déjà ne
parlait pas trois mots de français et
moi même j'étais pas au courant du sujet
de la manifestation s'était pas loin du
jeu on était juste là pour [__] la
merde et se marrer un peu quoi à vous
raconter l'épopée pinte donc les stinky
toys ces fameux stinky toys et puis
alors vous avez à londres et vous
rencontrez des sex pistols et vous
découvrez qu'en fait c'est un groupe
complètement bidon vous dites c'est
comme un boys band quoi bon aller aux
ordres de malcolm mclaren johnny rotten
mclane lui dit tu sors pas du placard il
sort pas quoi oui c'est vrai mais c'est
pas comme un boys band c'est un bruit
c'est un boys band mais c'est pas pour
autant que c'est mauvais c'est un très
très bon groupe de rock
moi je me souviens de concert c'était
vraiment pas mal mais néanmoins faut
savoir que c'est vraiment un boys band
c'est une fabrication mclaren way par
casting ouais sauf que justement le mec
qui faisait les morceaux qui justement a
été viré quelques vieilles malles toc il
ya des morceaux bas m'a dit eh oui mais
il était dérangeant
alors vous raconter l'invention de
l'épinglé à nourrice par paris
ça s'est passé à londres le les
histoires de punk c'est c'est un deal de
mclaren principalement un magasin de
fringues qui s'appelait sexe ki moon
était associé avec vivienne westwood et
donc que leur but du jeu c'est de vendre
des fringues soit avec un groupe de rock
comme les sex pistols ou etc donc quand
tu vois ilic a résulté pour talons
franchement raccommoder exclusivement à
base de d'épinglés à nourrice les
hausses assez bien
la semaine d'après c'est en vente c'est
du g13 et mystifiant sur le pont godbout
qu'un
nom mais je trouve sympa démystifiant de
devoir justement ça rend les choses un
peu plus humaine de voir que rivière
thur des businessman derrière des types
qui font d'eux ils font des trucs parce
que ça ne retire pas le talent de le
talent des uns ont parlé de pâques à 10
du night clubbing et puis la défense
avant vous êtes gravement accrocher la
dot non
ouais moi en ce qui me concerne
ça a duré assez peu de temps mais d'une
façon très concentrée
maximum pendant un an peu de toi ça a
duré plus longtemps devraient pas
exagérer
tous les soucis là j'en avais tu crois
que non mais pendant un an oui très fort
je teste toutes les drogues qui existent
sur la planète en allant et puis tout
d'un coup ça a été j'ai senti le danger
se dirait et donc je suis allé au
château du visage c'est une clinique
elle relativement fascistes mais qui
tu ressors clean mais tu as survécu oui
oui
contre à moi toi qui me semble un peu
non
l'itinéraire du dandy pop aux éditions
du rocher
c'est tout
on a changé les tests
bonjour les rouges ap sophie soulignac
et nathalie vincent
oui
les jeunes
y'a de la meuf ce soir c'est cool quand
la ch'ti et la stib a pas
d'accord à 100 on est content
tous
les chanteurs ticket va adorer
alors tout l'été vous faites starmag
tous les jours à 19h55 sur tps star ça
consiste en quoi sophie c'est une heure
d'émission de cinéma je voulais jour
avec une bande de jeunes qui adore le
cinéma qui essaye de transmettre leur
enthousiasme en allant voir plein de
films c'est comme un boulot très
difficile pour connaître des tiac années
filent ah oui vous avez qui comme star
dans votre émission là beaucoup
de
bien audrey tautou beyoncé knowles jamie
foxx tu vois bien alors tout va bien
on a eu dany boon quand même vous
attendez
on a gardé le meilleur pour la fin à ses
jours si vous avez vu ce film bien sûr
pas malin ce débat je ferai plus jamais
de travaux chez moi mais apparaître va
bien alors pour mettre les dix j'appelle
jérôme foucault
le murano urban louisot une eau de
murano laurine du must go der limmat
sillage tu connais toi oui ou merci date
est
mignonne plus et des riches bon
bah oui faut bien
on sait pas c'est si elle va être
diffusé ce nom
ça c'est pour la chaîne c'est un pilote
bien tu es prêt jérôme on y va bon alors
vous connaissez le principe d'abord
c'est l'équipe de jacno contre l'équipe
de nolwenn à je suis responsable il faut
mettre sa responsable quelque chose une
fois dans ta vie
responsable de voeux d'énormément de
choses de vie mais là du blind test
c'est un peu dur comme un tuba voilà
c'est ton équipe voilà et donc l'équipe
de nolwenn attention mais c'est vers
syrte avec nolwenn mois jérôme
quoi
avait pas venu pour perdre un talus bien
ça fait un point pour l'équipe de
nolwenn évidemment numéro 2 0
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la caméra
on
à
j'ai vite dit
[Musique]
gaccio nettoyeurs
non
[Musique]
quincy jones bravo
bravo
continue geo
tout se sait
tan sang froid
bon alors ça fait quoi rêver car
qu'est-ce qu'on a emballé la tuera les
flocons après l'assaut ça fait deux
points pour l'équipe de nolwenn quand
même
alouettes a gagné la star ac' alep-hama
boeing gagnait blind test vous allez
voir chez roccat
[Musique]
l'idée
dany tu as connu la tl marrant
tu allais génial alors
de qui on continue jérôme
non my name is now
à
[Musique]
il faut que disent leurs hommes pour
qu'ils trouvent ce nom c'est la télé sur
le bout des ongles
lorsque je sais qui connait barry
manilow copacabana alors vous en est où
là
on y va c'est normal d'aller en
afghanistan tout le temps
revel de l'express et pas rock et folk
mais vous la
semiac bas ce qui vous attend c'est ton
métier
cinéma chez moune euros
dans les déchets
utiliser une bombe
charles benoit
jean la merde
oh
non c'est bien parce que j'ai entendu la
fin j'ai honte d'avoir trouvé pourquoi
n'ont ils pas les irlandais n'ont pas
dit non non c'est vrai puis estime à
dieu toi souchon et voulzy parce qu'il
avait fait une parodie de cette chance
sébastien fait pour ça je te 70,8
tti do
quand même
m
[Musique]
oui
c'est une chanson les paroles sont nuls
oui moi je dis c'est trois points en
plus un ça va cette performance fils
hilarante retrouvé rapidement enfin j'ai
dit laura le manteau
[Applaudissements]
les biterrois
wen je le fais passer
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est bon un très bon
rythme elle rit oui jo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
5 pour nolwenn trois projets qui n'ont
pas le choix
le mondial ménages attention attention
ce n'est qu'une tricherie enfin c'est
patrice bresciani doute là dessus ah non
non non ouais mais bon pourtant est
riche à la stac là les greens
on continue jérôme
âgées
ouais
c'est
m
vous
c c'est un régal boudé il reconnaît au
bouton me fait chier parce qu'il est
rapide mais j'avais reconnu aussi vite
il est vrai que s'habille comme elle
aussi
il a des qualités on sait qu'il fait des
vannes dans la fulgurance et ils se
trouvent les les chansons des bleus à
une thèse sur les intros voilà est plus
qu à trouver du travail
de recommandation c'est assez précis
c'était c'est précis comme savoir faire
mais il peut trouver des choses il ya
des télés en afghanistan et non
est en arabie saoudite tu peux trouver
un bien sûr en burqa causé d'autres le
pied du boulot
jérôme
[Musique]
au lait ce tournoi
nle
[Musique]
je conseille aux jeunes générations cet
album c'est un diplomate wikango un
homme qui dure onze minutes 35 je
conseille ça non ouais vous y allez
matin muni du we need you under my thumb
adama thiam s'ajouter au titre en
faisons encore un petit bout non c'est
difficile
[Musique]
mathis tôt cette semaine
[Applaudissements]
com
bien on continue jérôme ils font plus
rien à dire
non à leurs travaux
c'est
l'original était deuxième ouais bah
bravo bravo ouais enfin c'est de la
musique de michel
jérôme
[Musique]
je les mettre sur mon i pod le strict at
je sais pas si bien oui ah ouais c'est
magnifique c'est vrai et après tu te
fais un tatouage bien oui je me fais là
voilà donc un issu du par équipes c'est
l'équipe de nolwenn qui gagne avec une
fois
non
ce soit dans d'obésité et c'est vrai
messieurs ces jeux d'une part éclipsé la
fin du parti maintenant c'est le chacun
pour sa gueule chacun pour sa gueule je
ne vous étonnez c'est le libéralisme
voilà j'ai plus d'amis attention on y va
le bronco jérôme
bondu rien non
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
oui
les bas rhinois écoutant je cherche
c'est la guerre
exact mais la raison c'est que trop de
robbie williams eut peut remettre le
trophée vient l'arrêter robes et à la
raison il ya bien pompé ont
bien
servi et nous on dit bravo ouais fumier
alors maintenant on passe à l'ultra
banco c'est très très très très
difficile c'est un groupe que j'adore
personnellement mais bon peut-être
suis-je le seul en attentions se
concentrent tous mais tant que tu trouve
toi ça va tomber des années 80 cette
mère de la whey exactement ils sont
venus à lunettes noires pour nuits
blanches
depeche mode and on attend
il a quand même pas de chanson par
jacques attention mais tu peux trouver
toi allons-y djhero
technique
[Musique]
c'est dur
madness
à neuf
la caméra
retour à tant que chef thierry pardon je
n'y retourne à sa place à bord il y
avait but et dinh nord du groupe d'abord
c'est prefab sprout boisvert
y avait aussi une chanson géniale
chapelet et manhattan de prefab sprout
et king of rock and roll c'est vraiment
un très bon groupe bien là donc à
l'issue alors rebecca qui a gagné c'est
thierry barba monsieur
voilà c'est justement parlant une
excellente émission thierry quoi qu'on
en dise et quoi qu'on en pense c'était
tout le monde en parle cinéma c'était
tout moment par les gardes à vue
florence moncorgé gabin le passager de
l'été avec catherine frot grégori
derangère françois berléand et mathilde
seigner sortie le 7 juin mesdames
messieurs nolwenn leroy album merci sap
et d'histoire naturelle elle est en
concert les 9 et 10 octobre à l'olympia
et en tournée dans toute la france dany
boon la maison du bonheur que dany boon
aller michèle laroque il est dit mme
voynet l'organe l'on à une renault
initial aurait entendu sortie le 7 juin
renaud revel pipeau le grand déballage
avec lens de bruyne chez michel lafon
tarak ben ammar et la belgique
arthur et les minimoys bernard brochand
pouvait réussir l'impossible selon
berlin brochand de pierre bénite que ja
ja timée éditions anne nivat les
islamistes comment ils nous voient des
parlements les plaines d'asie centrale
dès que chez fayard laureline goldberger
iphone en plus beau laisser chez fleuve
noir et jacno l'album s'appelle tant de
temps voilà plus itinéraire bis en hip
hop avec albert algoud ces deux éditions
du rocher sophie soulignac nathalie
vincent starmag tous les jours à 19h55
sur tps star
les gens nouveaux l'album dont on va
entendre pendant le générique de fin
s'appelle peace index voilà c'est fait
on en passe rendez vous la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
il
c
[Musique]
mais bon
oh
je
[Musique]
oui
un mot anglais
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu